Das ist kein Test, das klingt ganz gut.
Ulrich sag mal Test.
Super, endlich wieder eine Test-Sendung. Das war Chaosradio 117.
Ja, wir wünschen euch alles Gute, wir lösen uns auf. Um hinterher wieder Vereinigung.
Wir probieren nochmal, oder?
Wir probieren nochmal. Herzlich willkommen, hier ist das Chaosradio 117. Hallo.
Schönen guten Tag, wir sind's.
Im Studio Tim, Andreas und Ulrich. Ulrich ist ein neuer Name, den hatten wir noch nicht hier. Hallo Ulrich.
Hallo zusammen.
Wer hat dich denn eingeladen?
Ich glaube der Tim, oder?
Äh, ja ich bin schuld.
Haben wir schon gesagt, worum es geht?
Das ist doch jetzt erstmal um Ulrich.
Das Thema der Sendung ist Ulrich.
Das Thema der Sendung ist vor allem lange angekündigt gewesen und war ja auch schon der Kandidat für den letzten Monat und dann haben wir das nochmal verschoben, weil das terminlich einfach nicht gepasst hat. Und jetzt gehen wir das mal an und das Thema lautet Wahlcomputer. Es ist ja sehr verbreitet, dazu auch Wahlmaschinen zu sagen, aber aus bestimmten Gründen, die wir hier auch noch ausführlich darlegen wollen, sprechen wir von Wahlcomputern. Und wir hatten auch glaube ich noch so einen ganz fetzigen Untertitel. Ach ja, der schleichende Untergang der öffentlichen Kontrolle. Also es geht um Wahlen und es geht um Wahlen mit automatisierenden Systemen im Besonderen. Und dazu haben wir hier auch zum Beispiel den Ulrich eingeladen. Vielleicht können wir das ja gleich mal voranstellen. Du hast Klage eingereicht oder Widerspruch eingereicht, wie lautet die offizielle Bezeichnung?
Ich habe Einspruch eingelegt gegen das Wahlergebnis der Bundestagswahlen in Wahlkreisen, wo Wahlcomputer eingesetzt worden sind.
Und genau, das ist der eine Grund, warum wir dich eingeladen haben. Der andere Grund ist, dass du auch schon auf dem letzten Kongress, auf dem 22C3 einen Vortrag darüber gehalten hast. Die Aufzeichnung gibt es auch im Netz dazu. Und dann haben wir noch Andreas, der sich auch schon ein bisschen näher die Nase in diese Technologie mit reingesteckt hat. Ja und ich bin für die dummen Kommentare zuständig. Ich dachte, das wär ich. Aber wir haben natürlich ein total seriöses Thema. Ist die Hintergrundmusik jetzt eigentlich laut? Ah, jetzt ist sie leiser. Wir haben ein total seriöses Thema ausgesucht, weil es geht ja um die Demokratie und wir sind ja eigentlich ganz besorgt. Ich bin ja so ein bisschen der Berufsoptimist im CCC.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
Ich sehe das immer alles total rosig. Ich muss sagen, in letzter Zeit vergeht mir das ja. Also ich hab jetzt echt lange so die Schnauze voll. Warum?
Also nur wegen der Wahlcomputer?
Nee.
Ich bin unsufrieden mit der Gesamtsituation.
Ja gut, das sind wir ja alle schon seit Jahren. Darum klagen wir auch ständig.
Ja, aber hast du mal irgendwie in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen durch das Internet geblättert, was einem da so permanent vor die Nase gehalten wird? Also es nimmt jetzt einfach gar kein Ende. Die Bundesregierung zum Beispiel ist ja jetzt der Mann, und man müsste jetzt mal wieder was gegen Hacker tun. Ganz neues Thema, hurra. Hacker Tools verbieten und tun auf einmal so, als wäre das mal wieder so ein ganz großes Problem. Der Druck kommt da im Wesentlichen aus europäischen Gefilden.
Na ja, in Europa, also die EU macht ja nichts, was die Regierungschefs nicht wollen, von daher.
EU ist immer eine gute Ausrede, um Dinge national durchzusetzen.
Genau. Wir hören uns ja nicht zum ersten Mal, sondern die Diskussion gab es vor einiger Zeit schon. Eigentlich hat sich auf breiter Ebene mittlerweile schon doch auch ein bisschen der Gedanke durchgesetzt, dass man auch Sicherheitsanalysen anstellen muss und dazu natürlich auch die passenden Werkzeuge braucht, um Sicherheit überhaupt erst herzustellen. Wenn man jetzt losgeht und versucht, die Werkzeuge zu verbieten, dann trifft es halt die Falschen.
Ich dachte, Sicherheit geht, indem wir überwachen.
Das ist ja das nächste Thema mit dem Überwachen. Also wenn es nur die Hacker Tools wären, hätte ich ja vielleicht noch gute Laune. Aber bei dem Überwachen geht es ja dann gleich weiter. Was hast du gerade noch erzählt? Das hatte ich heute schon überblättert. In Brandenburg gibt es jetzt ein Gesetz zur präventiven Wohnraumüberwachung?
Also es gibt ein neues Polizeigesetz. Ich muss gestehen, ich habe es noch nicht vollständig geklickt, aber das, was ich dann auszügen gelesen habe, da entstanden einem schon die Haare zu Berge. Das ist ja auch ein Trend, den man beobachtet, dass immer weniger von der Strafverfolgung gebraucht gemacht wird, sondern präventiv verhindert wird. Und das klingt schon alles ein bisschen nach Gesündungskontrolle. Naja, trägt zu der unschönen Gesamtsituation bei. Nichts zu vergessen, die Anti-Terror-Dateien.
Also Jörg Schönbohm, Entschuldigung, Jörg Schönbohm, das ist der Innenminister, der immer so klingt, als hätte er einen gezwitschert, der sagt, dass die neuen Regelungen ein Gewinn an Sicherheit für jeden einzelnen Bürger bedeuten würden.
Bin überzeugt.
Find ich gut. Ich wollt nur mal die andere Seite auch zu Wort kommen lassen.
Ja, die sind so weltfremd.
Ja, Anti-Terror-Datei ist glaube ich auch noch ein ganz wichtiges Stichwort. Die Trennung von Polizei und Geheimdienstarbeit, die nach diesem Krieg wieder eingeführt wurden, nachdem es schlechte Erfahrungen mit der Gestapo gab, die wurde jetzt wieder aufgehoben und Polizei und Geheimdienste dürfen jetzt endlich wieder zusammenarbeiten, um die Terroristen, wollte ich sagen, verfolgen zu können. Und so geht das eigentlich nur die ganze Zeit weiter. Das mit den Wahlcomputern ist halt auch so ein Problem. Schrittweise wird an allen Grundrechten rumgeknabbert und das, was bei den Wahlcomputern zum Spiel steht, ist einfach das Recht auf freie, gleiche und geheime Wahlen.
Ich kann nur abstimmen gehen.
Ich geh nur rein, stimme ab. Alles super.
Genau.
Und ich muss nicht mehr schreiben können. Ich muss nicht mehr schreiben können. Ich muss nicht mehr in X schreiben können.
Ja, aber da will ja jemand ein X für ein U vormachen. Da sollte man sozusagen schon mal noch ein bisschen genauer drauf schauen. Ja, also grundsätzlich geht es um Folgendes. Es geht darum, dass es zunehmende Bestrebungen gibt, auch in Deutschland, aber leider nicht nur in Deutschland. In anderen Ländern teilweise noch viel intensiver als hier. Aber auch hier geht es langsam los. Das bekannte Wahlsystem, das zettelbasierte Wahlsystem durch Geräte zu bereichern, sodass man eben nicht mehr Stift und Zettel benutzt, sondern dass man eben ein Gerät benutzt. Und es gibt da eben eine ganze Reihe von Argumenten dafür. Und natürlich gibt es auch eine ganze Reihe von Argumenten dagegen. Unsere Auffassung nach, das können wir hier schon mal vorweg nehmen, sind die Argumente dagegen so wichtig, dass die Argumente dafür eigentlich gar nicht groß zählen. Trotz alledem wollen wir das ganz gerne mal ein bisschen aufschlüsseln. Und wir haben vorhin uns ein wenig zusammengesetzt und uns gedacht, wir fangen mal vorne an, indem wir mal erstmal anschauen, was eigentlich eine Wahl heutzutage ausmacht. Also was geschieht da eigentlich tatsächlich? Warst du wählen? Warst du jetzt gerade gewählt hier in Berlin?
Natürlich war ich wählen.
Bist du gemeldet?
Ich bin gemeldet und ich war wählen. Ich habe, das kann ich leider nicht sagen, ich wohne ja in Kreuzberg. Gleichzeitig war ja BVV, also Bezirksverordnetenversammlungswahl. Und ich dachte mir, in Kreuzberg gönne ich mir mal den Spass- und Wähl-CDU. Hat super funktioniert. Ich glaube, die haben 8% oder irgendwie sowas. Nein, eigentlich mache ich das, weil ich auf Zucht und Ordnung stehe und wirklich diese laissez faire, laissez passé Haltung, die Kreuzberg den ganzen Tag so an den Tag legt, wirklich nicht dulde. Alles voll geschmiert, der Müll auf der Straße. Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm, schlimm, schlimm.
Aber das glauben wir dir jetzt nicht, ne?
Was? Dass ich mein Kreuzberg-CDU gemacht habe? Ja natürlich, die hätten das so oder so verloren. Die Grünen gewinnen da eh. Ich will auch immer den Spaß können.
Okay, du siehst es aus einem sportlichen Aspekt heraus. Ich dachte, jetzt kommt hier irgend so was wie, ja, ich nehme die Demokratie.
Nein, auf Landesebene nehme ich das sehr, sehr ernst. Sehr, sehr ernst unter Saurier, nicht weil ich gewählt habe.
Okay, also das war sozusagen nur der BVV-Spaß.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wo die BVV tagt. Wo tagt die BVV? Ich höre. Komm, irgendjemand wird das wissen. 0331 70 97 110 Wo tagt die BVV? Also die jeweilige BVV.
Ja, hier gibt es auch mehrere. Im Kreuzberg, keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne einen einzigen Menschen, der jemals von der BVV war.
Okay, na das können wir ja mal rauskriegen. Ansonsten würden wir uns auch von den Hörern durchaus auch Feedback zu unserem Thema wünschen. Vor allem, ob es Leute gibt, die bei der letzten Wahl Wahlhelfer gewesen sind. Und wann war denn eigentlich die letzte Wahl in Brandenburg?
Oh, kürzlich, vergangenes Jahr.
Die Kommunalwahl? Und falls noch jemand weiß, wann war die letzte Wahl in Brandenburg?
Wann tagt die BVV? Wann waren die letzten Wahlen in Brandenburg? Und wie sieht es eigentlich als Wahlhelfer aus? Also falls ihr als Wahlhelfer unterwegs wart, bei irgendeiner Wahl, bei der letzten in Berlin, oder bei irgendeiner schon mal dabei wart, ruft an 0331 70 97 110 und erzählt, wie es da so zugeht. Also ob ihr auch Spaß beim Auszählen habt.
Also besonders würden uns Wahlhelfer interessieren aus Doppelpunkt Cottbus, Teltow, Hoppegarten, Friedersdorf, Neunhagen oder Trebin.
Warum?
Weil da Wahlcomputer eingesetzt werden.
Tatsächlich, wurden schon.
Ja.
Bei der letzten Kommunalwahl. Also das sind auch die einzigen Wettbewerbe in Brandenburg. Oh, Entschuldigung, bei der Bundestagswahl.
Aber dann braucht man doch keine Wahlhelfer mehr, wenn sowieso der Computer da steht.
Das muss ja schon jemand dafür, also da muss jemand an diesem Schlüsselschalter drehen und das Knöpfchen drücken und den Strich in der Liste machen, das diejenige gewählt hat. Also man braucht dann nicht mehr so viele Leute, aber da muss schon noch jemand sein.
Also fangen wir mal an, also stell dir mal vor, ist es Wahl.
Warte mal, wir müssen gerade noch unser BVV-Problem klären.
Achso, und hast du schon eine Antwort?
Name Boris. Wo tagt die BVV?
Ja, ich wollte noch mal ein bisschen den staatspolitischen quasi Defiziten auf die Sprünge helfen. Die BVV hat früher im Schöneberg Rathaus getagt und mittlerweile im Abgeordnetenhaus am Anhalter Bahnhof. Das ist das Abgeordnetenhaus, die über vom Magentüden Kopius baus. Da tagt nämlich die BVV.
Also auch da, wo der Landtag ist.
Genau.
Das ist also da, wo keiner von der CDU aus Kreuzberg sitzt.
Ja, das ist ein interessantes Thema. Die CDU, also da könnten wir vielleicht einen kleinen Schwenken machen. Ich möchte mich vielleicht nochmal bei allen Berlinerinnen und Berlinern bedanken, dass wir den Friedbergflüger erfolgreich in die Luft geschlagen haben.
Ich glaube, das hat er zuvor das selbst gemacht.
Ja, aber das Ding ist, letzten Endes gab es noch ein paar Versprengte, die irgendwie gedacht haben, der arme Junge hätte irgendwie eine Möglichkeit oder eine Chance in dieser Stadt.
Ich glaube, Berlin ist einfach pleit und alle merken es und alle wissen noch, wer es war.
Eben alle wissen, wer es war.
Auf der anderen Seite Flüger, also wir als Berliner, wir wollen sowas nicht. Ich hatte noch ein paar Hintergrunddetails, falls jemand Interesse daran hätte. Der Friedberg ist ja wirklich eine interessante Sache. Der ist so eine Lachnummer, dass man da schon einiges zu sagen sollte.
Ja gut, aber der ist ja jetzt nicht wirklich Thema der Sendung.
Wir machen das mal anders, Boris. Wir werden einfach mal im Rahmen der beliebten Sendung Die Welt ist klein, das ist der Montagsblumen, eine Politiker-Bashing-Sendung machen. Da darf jeder anrufen und gemeine Details über Politiker seines größten Misstrauens erzählen.
Ein kleines Highlight.
Ein Highlight, aber dann ein Highlight nehmen wir.
Ein Highlight? Also der gute Flüger, der hat ja seinen Sitz im Bundestag. Was macht er mit seinen Praktikantinnen? Flachlegen auf dem Schreibtisch und alle gucken zu. Das ist kein Quatsch, das ist nicht irgendwie ausgedacht. Meine damalige Freundin hat zu der Zeit im Bundestag ihr Praktikum gemacht und das war einfach der Running Gag.
Entschuldigung, Friedbert Flüger hat deine Freundin auf dem Schreibtisch flach?
Nein, ja nicht meine Freundin, weil dann wäre Friedbert Flüger gar nicht mehr zu der Wahl angetreten. Das ist eine Rolle, die er da sich als Praktikantin an Land gezogen hat.
Du bist hoffentlich in der Lage, im Zweifelsfall diesen Nachweis zu führen. Nämlich je nachdem, wer jetzt gerade hier zuhört, wird er den RBB auf Herausgabe deiner Nummer verklagen.
Das ist ja sowas von Latte, weil a, haben wir irgendwo in Deutschland noch eine Meinungsfreiheit. Das sollte dir auch noch bekannt sein.
Ja sicher, aber ich kann mich nicht einfach hinstellen und sagen, Friedbert Flüger nagelt Praktikantin auf dem Schreibtisch. Da sollte ich dann schon als Beleg zu haben. Meinung und Beleg.
Ich habe freundlich mit dem darin Zehlendorf abgeordneten Brauns Lehmann gesprochen, der hat mir die Geschichte nochmal bestätigt. Und was ja auch noch interessant ist, was eigentlich alle wissen sollten, der Flüger ist sowas von einer armen Wurst, er ist ja politisch erst groß geworden durch seine Frau, die ihres Ursprungs Griechen ist, die eine große SPD-Größe ist, und in ihr Leben einiges angestellt hat, macht der Flüger, er hängt sich ran. Er lässt sich von ihr scheiden und hat auch noch die Dreistigkeit von ihr Unterhalt zu verlangen.
Boris, Boris, es reicht, es reicht. Es geht um Wahlcomputer.
Er kann sich gerne bei mir melden, ich sag dir das alles noch persönlich.
Alles klar, ich stell dich noch mal raus zum Einbeinigen, der nimmt dann deine Nummer auf und falls Friedberg Flüger dann mit dir in Kontakt treten will, soll Friedberg Flüger einfach den Einbeiner.
Ich darf mit Captain Hook sprechen?
Nein, der hat nur ein Bein, der Arme.
Der Einbeinige.
Captain Hook hat einen Haken.
Stimmt, jetzt hast du wieder recht.
Ich danke für deinen Anruf. Danke, tschüss. Ist euch eigentlich auch schon mal der Gedanke gekommen, dass wir in der Twilight Zone sind?
Ich komm gar nicht mehr raus.
Ich wollte gerade so was sagen wie zurück zum Thema.
Holger, du warst wählen.
Ich war wählen, genau.
Was hast du denn da getan?
Da habe ich...
Also ich will es jetzt genau wissen.
Da habe ich gesagt, hallo, ich habe meine Wahlbenachrichtigung verbaselt, aber hier ist mein Personalausweis.
Ist das nicht dein Ernst?
Ja, das ist mein Ernst.
Ah, das hat funktioniert?
Das funktioniert natürlich. Du musst nur wissen, was dein Wahllokal ist.
Und dann hat dein Analyste nachgeschaut?
Ich gucke dein Analyste nach, mach ein Häkchen, dass du da warst. Damit die, die hinter nicht wählen gegangen sind, hinterher Besuch von irgendwen kriegen können. Dann werden mir die Unterlagen ausgehändigt. Also, es waren was? Vier Zettel. Drei, vier, ne?
Vier?
Vier.
Stimmt.
Vier Zettel.
Unter anderem die Verfassungsänderung. Dann bin ich in die Wahlkabine gegangen, hab meine Kreuzchen gemacht.
Warst du da allein?
Da war ich allein. Okay. Also es waren drei Wahlkabinen da. Ich war allein in der Wahlkabine. In der mittleren.
Und? Da? Hast du dann was getan?
Kreuzchen gemacht, Kreuzchen gemacht, Kreuzchen gemacht. Kreuzchen gemacht, raus, also gefaltet.
War das für dich verständlich?
Das war für mich absolut verständlich, ja. Okay, du hast auf keinen Fall was getan. Ja, auf der Wahlbenachrichtigung, mit der Wahlbenachrichtigung. Das Einzige, was unverständlich hätte sein können, wäre ja diese Verfassungsänderung gewesen. Und da ist ja so ein Infoblatt mit der Wahlbenachrichtigung gekommen.
Was du gelesen hast als vor möglicher Bürger.
Was ich gelesen hab, ja natürlich.
Also ich saß ja auch in einer Wahlkabine und zu meiner Linken und zu meiner Rechten war ein Wahlkabin. Und da saß ein Ehepaar und sie brüllte zu ihm rüber. Du, was muss ich denn da ankreuzen? Und er warte, ich komm mal vorbei. Und da sind die also hinter meiner Wahlkabine, hinter meinem Rücken quasi hin und her gelaufen, haben sich gegenseitig beim Ausfüllen geholfen, bis der Wahlvorstand also dann eingriff und ihn erklärte, dass es a, nicht rechtens sei, hinter mir lang zu laufen und b, auch nicht rechtens sei, dazu mehreren in der Wahlkabine zu stehen und c, schon gar nicht das laut zu annunzen, was man gerade ankreuzt. Und hier wäre nochmal das Faltblatt, falls Sie Fragen hätten.
Und was ist passiert?
Sie haben sich dann geeinigt, sind wieder in die Wahlkabine gegangen und ich war in der Lage, mein Wahlgeheimnis durch vollen Körpereinsatz zu schützen.
Diskursive Demokratie, finde ich gut.
Aber du hast gefaltet. Was hast du nach dem Falten getan?
Zur Ohne gegangen, reingeschmissen, Danke gesagt gekriegt, mich selbst bedankt, nach Hause gegangen.
Falsch!
Ich bin zu Thomas gefahren. Ich bin zu Thomas gefahren, da haben wir uns einen gedampft und die Hochrechnungen geguckt.
Okay, hast du nicht die Lust verspürt, vielleicht gleich da zu bleiben? Nein, Wahl...
Wahllokal.
Nein, da war so ekelhafte Luft drin, dass ich gedacht...
Und wie viele Leute waren da so? Also die da so Dienst übernommen haben?
Drei saßen da, glaube ich, drei.
Gut, das war die Wahl. Was haben wir jetzt gemerkt? Also vor allem, du wählst halt sozusagen auch einen Zettel und du bist total sicher, dass das, was in der Urne gelandet ist, auch tatsächlich das war, was du angekreuzt hast, weil der ganze Weg für dich nachvollziehbar ist.
So sieht's aus.
Richtig?
Und wenn du Lust gehabt hättest, hättest du auch noch da bleiben können und beim Auszählen zugucken. Das ist nämlich alles komplett öffentlich.
Aber da gab's kein Bier.
Aber ich glaube, das wissen viele Leute gar nicht. Dass man also, wenn man sozusagen Lust verspürt, diesen Prozess zu überwachen, dass man das einfach so tun kann. Man kann einfach hingehen und sagen, hallo, ich will hier aufpassen und mir das alles, oder mit auszählen sogar, oder?
Mit auszählen glaube ich nicht, aber du kannst zu irgendwie auszählen.
Also mit auszählen, das machen nur die, die auch vorher diese Schulungen bekommen haben. Aber dafür kann man sich halt im Vorfeld auch.
Wenn du echt viel Zeit hast, dann kommst du morgens um acht an und guckst die ganze Zeit zu, wie gewählt wird und wie die eingreifen, wenn hinter dir irgendwelche Leute hergehen oder sich Leute in der Wahlkabine beraten wollen.
Hast du das schon mal gemacht?
Den ganzen Tag?
Den ganzen Tag. Da wären die doch nervös oder nicht?
Der Typ, der sitzt die ganze Zeit da rum.
Und dann bleibst du dabei und guckst zu, wie ausgezählt wird und kann es wirklich zusehen, erstens, dass die alle ihre Stimme geheim abgeben und dass die Stimmen, die in der Ohne landen, die sind, die aus den Wahlkabinen kommen und dass die, die hinterher ausgezählt sind, die, die vorhin in der Ohne waren.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal zurückkommen auf das Grundgesetz, das die Grundlage für diesen Wahlprozess bildet. Das fordert nämlich freie, gleiche und geheime Wahlen. Und ich denke, wir sollten mal drauf eingehen, was das bedeutet und wie sich das konkret in diesem Wahlverfahren manifestiert. Also frei ist, sagt, dass jeder die Möglichkeit haben muss, die Stimme so abzugeben, wie er das gerne möchte. Also erst mal muss man überhaupt die Möglichkeit haben zu wählen, rechtzeitig informiert werden, da zu sein, sich über das politische Angebot vorher ein Bild machen.
Was heißt eigentlich rechtzeitig? Gibt es da irgendwie eine Zahl, also in Tagen, Wochen, Monaten?
Ja, du weißt doch, wie das ist mit Grundrechten. Das ist immer Auslegungssache. Aber ich denke, dass es da irgendwo auch eine Vorschrift gibt, die sagt, bis wann man das haben muss. Also so und so vier Wochen vorher müssen die Wahlbenachrichtigungen verschickt sein. Zu frei gehört natürlich auch, dass keiner mit einer Knarre hinter einem steht und dir einen Kopf hält und einem sagt, was man zu wählen hat. Gleich. Gleichheit hat mehrere Effekte. Also gleich heißt natürlich erstens, jeder hat eine Stimme. Gleich reflektiert sich aber auch darin, dass es keine Möglichkeit besteht, die Wahl zu manipulieren, weil wenn jemand an der Wahl etwas manipulieren könnte, hätte er quasi mehr als eine Stimme. Also aus diesem Gleich folgert, dass eine Wahl sicher gegen Manipulation sein muss. Und geheim ist, glaube ich, auch noch ziemlich einfach erklärt. Es soll einen keiner bei der Stimmabgabe beobachten.
So wie man dich beobachtet hat.
So wie man mich, also wie gesagt durch massiven Körpereinsatz war ich in der Lage, das Wahlgeheimnis zu wahren. Ja und also einerseits, dass man in einer Wahlkabine steht. Also diese Wahlkabine erfüllt den Zweck, dass man bei der Stimmabgabe nicht beobachtet wird. Und auch das Falten, das du erwähnt hast, hat den Zweck, dass man, wenn man aus der Wahlkabine rausläuft, das Kreuze nicht mehr sieht. Und die Ohne, die da versiegelt ist, die ist natürlich wieder dazu da, die Sicherheit der Wahl sicherzustellen.
Die ist dann verblommt, oder?
Die ist versiegelt, ja.
Das gibt so einen Klebesiegel drüber, nicht? Ich würde das. Einen Anrufer haben wir, der hat eine Frage. Hallo Philipp.
Ja, hallo Holger. Und zwar, ich habe eine Frage, wo habt ihr eure Informationen, dass das jetzt irgendwie auf dem Wege ist mit Wahlcomputern? War das jetzt eine These oder ist das eine konkrete Sache, die ihr wisst oder ist es nur so ein Gefühl oder?
Nein, das ist überhaupt kein Gefühl, sondern das ist eine ganz konkrete Sache. Das hat angefangen 1999 in Köln, erstmalig bei der Europawahl und breitet sich seitdem so allmählich aus. Bei der Bundestagswahl sind insgesamt in fast 2000 Wahlbezirken Wahlcomputer im Einsatz gewesen, das sind ungefähr 5 Prozent.
Es ist seit 2000 schon Wahlcomputer eingesetzt worden?
Ja genau, in Köln. In Köln war der Vorreiter und jetzt bei den Bundestagswahlen waren flächendeckend Wahlcomputer im Einsatz, zum Beispiel auch in Dortmund, in Recklinghausen, in Cottbus glaube ich.
Und man hat keine, also kein Zettel mehr in die Hand bekommen und hat irgendwie ein Kreuzchen gemacht, oder was?
Man drückt einen Knopf.
Man drückt einen Knopf. Und wisst ihr auch darüber, ob man extra ungültig wählen kann? Gab es die Option dann auch?
Es gibt da eine Taste an diesen Wahlcomputern, da steht ungültig dran und dann gibt man seine Stimme ungültig ab. Ja, das geht.
Ja, also, weil das Ding, ich bin irgendwie relativ erschrocken. Also ich hab jetzt nicht gedacht, dass es so konkret ist, dass ich jetzt wieder, weil ich war auch schon irgendwie zweimal Wahlhelfer. Und genau das, was ich schon gesagt hab, also das heißt, dass es wirklich öffentlich ist, dass jeder Bürger einfach vorbeigehen kann. Also bei uns war das sogar, dass bei uns im Bezirk sogar der Bürgermeister sogar mit Tour durch die ganzen Wahllokale gemacht hat.
Philipp, Philipp, Philipp, wir müssen Nachrichten machen. Magst du so lange dranbleiben, bis nach den Nachrichten, dann mal ein bisschen aus dem Alltag eines Wahlhelfers erzählen? Alles klar, bleib dran. Danke für deinen Anruf, 1-2-1. Und wir machen Nachrichten jetzt.
Die exklusiven Fritz-Radio-Konzerte gehen schon wieder weiter. Diesmal mit A Fire Inside, kurz AFI. Fritz bringt euch ein exklusives Radio-Konzert mit AFI. Für Karten zum Dabeisein, fritz.de. Das exklusive Radio-Konzert mit AFI. Kommen in Dienstag ab 18 Uhr.
Auf allen Frequenzen von...
In Berlin unternimmt die Europäische Union seit dem frühen Abend einen möglicherweise letzten Versuch, den Iran im Atomstreit zum Einlenken zu bewegen. Dazu kamen EU-Chef Diplomat Solana und der iranische Chefunterhändler Laritschani zusammen. Das Treffen war am Rande der UN-Vollversammlung beschlossen worden. Die Gespräche werden vermutlich erst morgen abgeschlossen. Bundesgesundheitsministerin Schmidt hat die geplante Gesundheitsreform gegen scharfe Angriffe der Opposition verteidigt. Das Projekt habe zum Ziel, das Geld im Gesundheitswesen genauer und sparsamer einzusetzen und die Versorgung der Patienten zu verbessern, sagte die SPD-Politikerin in einer aktuellen Stunde im Bundestag. Das Versicherungssystem solle für alle bezahlbar bleiben. FDP, Linksfraktion und Grüne warfen der großen Koalition dagegen ein Scheitern auf ganzer Linie vor. In Berlin hat die erste deutsche Islamkonferenz ihre Arbeit aufgenommen. Nach dem dreistündigen Auftaktreffen zogen Bundesinnenminister Schäuble und die Vertreter der muslimischen Organisationen eine positive Bilanz. Mit der Konferenz will die Bundesregierung die gesellschaftliche Integration der Muslime in Deutschland verbessern und so auch den wachsenden Einfluss islamistischer Kräfte einlämmen. In Polen hat sich die innenpolitische Krise weiter zugespitzt. Bauernführer Leppe erstellte bei Staatspräsident Lech Kaczynski den Antrag, Ministerpräsident Jaroslaw Kaczynski und dessen Kabinett zu entlassen. Vor dem Parlamentsgebäude versammelten sich am Abend rund 200 Demonstranten und forderten den Rücktritt der Regierung. Zum Sport. In der UEFA Champions League laufen derzeit zwei Vorrundenhinspiele mit deutscher Beteiligung. Im Spiel Werder Bremen gegen den FC Barcelona steht es kurz vor Schluss 1-0 für Bremen. In der Partie Intermai-Land gegen den FC Bayern München führt Bayern ebenfalls mit 1-0. Heute Nacht letzte Schauer an der Neiße, ansonsten ziehen ein paar Wolkenfelder durch. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 13 bis 8 Grad. Am Tag ist es erst neblig trüb, später lockert es auf bei Höchstwerten um 22 Grad. A12 Berliner Ring Richtung Frankfurt-Boda. Am Grenzübergang Frankfurt staut es sich. Die letzte freie Ausfahrt ist Müllrose. A11 Autobahnzubringe Hamburg-Oranienburg Richtung Charlottenburg. Zwischen Saatwinkler Damm und Dreieck Charlottenburg ist der rechte Fahrstreifen wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Nochmal A11 Autobahnzubringe Hamburg-Charlottenburg Richtung Oranienburg. Im Tunnel Ortskern Tegel ist der linke Fahrstreifen wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Und in der Gegenrichtung ist der rechte Fahrstreifen ebenfalls wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Außerdem noch eine Meldung, die abendüber schon begleitet ist. In Hohen Neuendorf besteht Gefahr durch ausströmendes Gas, deshalb ist die Karl-Marx-Straße zwischen Berliner und Kurt-Tucholski-Straße gesperrt. Überall sonst eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, gleich drei Minuten nach halb elf.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6, dann Fritz in Berlin.
Chaos Radio 117 Wahlcomputer sind unser Thema heute Abend, bevor Philipp gleich aus dem Alltag eines normalen Wahlhelfers mit Zetteln und so weiter erzählt. Wollte Andreas noch mal kurz zu Wort kommen. Hallo Andreas. Guten Abend.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur zu dem ersten Anrufer noch kurz was klarstellen.
BVV war das, ne? BVV, genau.
Also ich hab nicht ganz verstanden deine Geringschätzung für diese Stimmabgabe hinsichtlich der BVV. Denn man sollte ja schon berücksichtigen, dass wir in dieser Demokratie relativ selten Stimmen zu irgendwas abgeben dürfen. Und die Bezirksverordnetenversammlung ist bei der derzeitigen Organisation im Land Berlin nicht so ganz unwichtig.
Weil sie die Bezirksämter wählt.
Und so ein Bezirksamt kann eine ganze Menge Dinge machen, weil zum Beispiel der Stadtrat von Mitte auf die Idee kommen kann, eine Laftreihe zu verbieten, wenn es ihm irgendwie gefällt, über baurechtliche Zuständigkeiten und ordnungsbehördliche Zuständigkeiten. Und diese Zusammensetzung des Bezirksamtes wiederum funktioniert ja nicht so, dass Mehrheiten dann eine Partei da rein wählen, sondern die werden gemischt besetzt nach dem Dihonschen Höchstzahlverfahren, sodass es dann auch eine Rolle spielt, wie stark eine bestimmte Fraktion in der Bezirksverordnung in Versammlung vertreten ist. Und danach richtet sich dann später wiederum die Zusammensetzung des jeweiligen Bezirksamtes. Und da kann dann eine Stimme zu viel für die CDU in Kreuzberg durchaus über den einen oder anderen Stadtratkosten mitentscheiden, sozusagen. Und diese BVVs tagen natürlich in jedem Bezirk woanders, in der Regel da, wo die Bezirksverwaltung sitzt, also in Spandau, im Rathaus Spandau, im Wedding, im Bezirk am Wedding, im Tempelhof Kreuzberg, im Rathaus Kreuzberg, glaube ich, und nicht im abgeordneten Haus. Und zum Flüger wollte ich noch sagen, man kann sicher viel Negatives über den Flüger sagen, aber dass er gelegentlich Praktikantinnen auf Schreibtischen vögelt, würde ich dann sogar zu den positiveren Dingen zählen, die man über ihn sagen könnte, wenn das zu treffen sein sollte.
Das war ein sehr schönes Plädoyer, jede Wahl ernst zu nehmen, Andreas. Vielen Dank.
In der Tat.
So, kommen wir zu Philipp.
Ja, aber das Thema Flüger ist jetzt aber auch echt beerdigt für diese Sendung. Wieso? Wieso?
Na, es reicht.
Das wussten wir aber, bevor er angetreten ist schon. Und der hat sich auch nicht...
Okay, wir holen nochmal unseren Anrufer hervor.
Ich mal konkret zu diesem Computer Ding, das ist zum Beispiel ein Aspekt. Also ich finde es eigentlich ziemlich beunruhigend. Aber zum Beispiel gibt es halt zum Beispiel so Stimmen, die sind eindeutig ungültig. Da gibt es zum Beispiel Leute, die schreiben ungültig. Oder es gibt Leute, die schreiben dann wirklich Aufsätze auf ihren Wahlzetteln, wie scheiße sie den Staat finden.
Was macht ihr dann damit? Also wo warst du Wahlhelfer?
Ich war in Neukölln, irgendwie in so einem kleinen Bezirk. Also ich komme jetzt nicht aus Neukölln, ich komme aus Kreuzberg, aber hat sich so ergeben, dass ich dann da ein Ort...
Wie bist du Wahlhelfer geworden? Freiwillig oder bist du gefreiwilligt worden?
Nee, nee, sehr, sehr, sehr freiwillig. Ich kannte Bekannte, die haben das alle gemacht. Und dann habe ich gesagt, naja, bin ich auch sonntags mit dabei. Und das ist aber auch schon, weiß ich nicht, ich glaube, zwei, drei Jahre her, ich weiß auch nicht mehr, wann, zu welcher Wahl das war. Ich glaube, das war auch eine Bezirksabgeordnetenwahl. Da war das sogar sogar die Wahl, wo, wo... Na, oh Gott, ich sehe, jetzt liegt er mir auf der Zunge, der CDU-Bürgermeister, der da gekappt worden ist. Was? Diebchen? Ja, genau, Diebchen, genau. Wo er gekappt worden ist und dann, wo bereits dann offiziell gewählt worden ist. Ich glaube, in dem Jahr war ich sogar Wahlhelfer. Und naja, auf jeden Fall ist es da so, dass es dann halt so eindeutige ungültige Wahlstimmen gibt. Und dann gibt es halt zum Beispiel bei meinem Wahlbezug gab es halt auch viele alte Leute. Die kamen dann auch halt alle morgens. Und dann gab es dann halt zum Beispiel so Stimmen. Da haben zum Beispiel Leute irgendwie mehrfach gewählt. Also da gab es dann zum Beispiel Leute, also das Ding ist, es ist so eine menschliche Ermessenssache. Da haben zum Beispiel Leute alles angekreuzt, außer eine Sache. Es muss halt zum Beispiel daraus herausgehen, ob da irgendwas eindeutiges rausgeht. Also zum Beispiel, wenn sie alles durchgekreuzt haben, außer eine Sache, war das dann halt zum Beispiel so eine Sache. Da sind dann so fünf Leute, die dann so abwägen, ob das jetzt eine gültige Stimme ist oder nicht. Und da es eine offizielle Sache ist, theoretisch kann es jeder sehen, dass es nicht mal so eine Sache ist, die jetzt irgendwie nach außen Bauch heraus ist.
Das heißt, das heißt, bis auf eins ist alles durchgestrichen, dann ist genau das, was nicht durchgestrichen ist, die Wahl, die getroffen wurde.
Genau, so was zum Beispiel. Und das wird dann halt mit allen so besprochen. Das ist eine sehr offizielle Sache und es gibt dann auch eine Liste tatsächlich für jeden Wahlhelfer noch mal zum Durchlesen, welche Stimme gültig ist oder nicht gültig. Und dann gibt es dann halt zum Beispiel so eine Sache, dass dann zum Beispiel bei alten Leuten, bei uns war das so, da gab es dann zum Beispiel zwei Kreuze auf einem Stimmzettel und da war das dann halt so, ich glaube, das waren zwei oder drei Stimmen, da war dann halt so passiert, da waren dann halt zwei Kreuze drauf, aber haben sich sozusagen saßen in der Wahlkabine und wussten nicht, was sie wählen wollten, haben dann ein Kreuz gemacht, haben sich umentschieden und haben sich das andere Kreuz, also die Wahl, die sie dann doch noch getroffen haben, ganz dick gemacht, weißt du? Also haben da, weiß ich nicht, 20.000 Mal das Kreuz gemacht, um zu sagen, das haben die gewählt und haben sich wahrscheinlich nicht getraut, zu sagen, wir hätten gerne einen neuen Wahlzettel.
Vielleicht wussten die gar nicht, dass es geht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das weiß wahrscheinlich niemand, dass man sich einfach einen neuen Wahlzettel geben lassen kann.
Und da denke ich zum Beispiel, wenn du da am Computer sitzt, gibst du eine Taste ein und sagst, vielleicht will ich das doch nicht wählen. Also das ist zum Beispiel auch eine Sache.
Also das Ding gibt es keine Zeitlimit. Die Frage, gibt es eine Korrektur?
Es gibt eine Korrektur. Man drückt eine Taste, damit kommt man am Display angezeigt, was man gedrückt hat, also damit auch irgendwie das, was auf der Taste drauf steht, mit dem Display übereinstimmt. Und dann drückt man nochmal irgendwie Druck, obwohl das Dämmknopf. Und dann darf man abstimmen. Und was mich interessiert, du warst ja als Wahlhelfer. Würdest du sagen, dass irgendjemand mit den Stimmen geschummelt hat, während du da warst?
Nee, gar nicht.
Bist du dir hundertprozentig sicher?
Also was meinst du jetzt mit geschummelt? Also ich weiß nicht, ich kann mir denken, worauf die hinauswählt.
Nein, wie geht die Auszählung ist erstmal die Frage. Ruf das einer quer durch den Raum. CDU, Grüne, FDP.
Also das Ding ist die Wahl ohne, wird morgens dann im Wahllokal abgestellt. Die wird versiegelt. Und dann, wenn die Wahl, weiß ich nicht, um 7 oder um 8 Uhr zu Ende ist offiziell, darf man sie aufmachen und da kann sozusagen jeder öffentlich sein. Bei uns war es sogar der Bezirksbürgermeister, der sogar zu der Zeit sogar bei uns zufällig da war. Und dann wird es erstmal gemacht, dann werden erstmal die ganzen Wahlzettel nach Parteien geordnet, die angekreuzt sind. Und dann, also um da irgendwie ein System zu haben. Und danach hat man halt diese riesen Stapel, also ungültig und jeder einzelne Partei. Und dann wird gezählt. Und meistens passiert es so, ich hab's auch von anderen Leuten gehört, die auch Wahlhelter waren. Es ist nun so, dass man durchzählt diese Zettel und man hat sofort die richtige Zahl. Sondern man muss das ja auch mit der Liste abgleichen, wie viele haben gewählt und wie viele Stimmen sind da. Also das heißt, es wird alles wieder zusammengerechnet, um da wieder eine Gegenziffer zu haben, ob das denn alle stimmen. Und bei uns hat das sogar, wir haben es sogar fünfmal gezählt, was glaube ich Rekord in unserem Ballokal war, weil da irgendeine Stimme durcheinander war.
Wie lange saß er denn da?
Das ging schon lange. Also ich glaube, wir haben über eine Stunde gebraucht eigentlich. Ja, also es war ziemlich lange, aber ich weiß nicht, wie wir es gewählt haben. Also wenn er so... Ja?
Wenn ich jetzt kommen würde und sagen würde, nächste Mal machst du wieder Wahlhelfer und pass auf, ich gebe dir 20.000 Euro und dafür gewinne ich. Würdest du das hinkriegen oder würde das nicht gehen?
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Also das Ding ist, du müsstest mindestens jeden bezahlen. Und zweitens wäre es dir zu auffällig. Also das Ding ist, wenn du in einem Bezirk tausend Stimmen hast und würdest, also die Zettel werden ja auch nicht weggeschmissen. Die gibt es ja dann irgendwie an den Bezirk, ich weiß nicht, wer das koordiniert. Also auf jeden Fall an die Leute, die die einzelnen Wahllokale koordinieren und dann den ganzen Bezirk zusammenfassen. Da gibt der Wahlleiter hin, die ganzen Stimmen ab, wie viele gewählt haben und wie viele Stimmen pro Partei waren. Und diese Stimmzettel werden aber nicht weggeworfen. Das heißt, es wäre unmöglich. Also das Ding ist, zum Beispiel wenn 1000 Leute wählen, könnte man jetzt nicht noch 1000 neue Wahlzettel nehmen und sie umändern.
Okay, aber ich meine, es gäbe ja so Möglichkeiten, sagen wir mal, es kommen ja nicht alle zur Wahl, die auf der Liste stehen. Und wenn dann gerade keiner da ist, dann gucken sich alle in die Augen, die da sitzen und kreuzen schnell einen Zettel an und werfen ihn rein. Da müssten aber schon alle zusammenhalten, die da sind, oder? Wenn da einer ist, der guckt und der nicht in der Verschwörung drin ist, dann funktioniert es nicht, oder wie würdest du das sehen?
Ja, aber wenn dann zum Beispiel einer reinkommt, da kann es ja auch nicht davon ausgehen, da kommen ja immer ständig Leute und es sind immer eine Schübe und das einer sieht, ist es aufgeflogen, oder? Also das Ding, ich glaube, dass du es dir einfach vorstellst und dann musst du dir das auch noch vorstellen, ein Wahllokal, um eine Wahl zu betrügen, müsstest du ziemlich viel Geld in der Tasche haben und dann auch noch ein Betrug, was da rechtlich wirkt. Also nicht nur, dass du eine Geldstrafe dann auf dich hättest und dann auch noch Urkundenfälschung und weiß nicht was, ist der Stress glaube ich nicht wert. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das möglich ist. Also wenn du weißt, wo es dann halt z.B. ländlicher ist, wo es dann halt nur ein Wahlkreis gibt und dann gibt es zehn Dörfer, wo in jedem Dorf 20 Leute wohnen, dann ist es vielleicht einfacher, aber ich glaube nicht. Ich wollte gerade euch was fragen. Also das Ding, wisst ihr eigentlich, wie das technisch abläuft? Irgendwie die Wahl mit dem Computer, läuft das über irgendwie ein Netzwerk oder läuft das gesteuert dann sogar noch über einen Server im Internet?
Klären wir im Laufe der Sendung noch. Hör bitte weiter zu. Noch sind wir am Anfang noch bei Wahlen im Allgemeinen. Wahlen im Besonderen mit Computern kommt dann demnächst, im Laufe der nächsten zwei Stunden noch dran.
Philipp kommt jetzt gleich dran.
Bescheutes fragen, hast du noch so eine CD von ich, Sven?
Was?
Ey, nicht jetzt. Das hier ist Chaos Radio. Für alle anderen Fragen schickst du bitte eine Mail. Danke für deinen Anruf, Philipp. Und wir haben noch eine Wahlhelferin, und zwar Julia.
Hallo, Julia.
Wo warst du Wahlhelferin? Auch in der Stadt oder im Land?
Nee, direkt in der Stadt in Pankow.
Wie bist du dazu gekommen?
Freiwillig. Ich hab einfach gedacht, Mensch, das ist bestimmt eine lustige Sache. Und dann hab ich mich angemeldet.
Wie bekommt man überhaupt Kenntnis darüber, dass man freiwillig Wahlhelfer werden kann?
Entweder in der Zeitung, also in der Berliner steht zum Beispiel immer drinnen, dass sie Wahlhelfer suchen, ansonsten über Freunde, die schon Wahlhelfer sind. Ja, also das ist jetzt nicht so schwierig.
Wie siehst du das? Kann man an irgendeinem Punkt die Wahl fälschen?
Nee, würde ich nicht sagen. Also erst mal hast du ja so und so viele Leute in deinem Wahllokal. Da müsstest du dann wirklich schon alle bestechen.
Wie ist es denn mit der Next-Hören-Instanz, also wo alle Wahllokale hinmelden, wie viele Stimmen da sind?
Nee, das glaube ich nicht, dass das möglich ist.
Warum nicht?
Ich weiß es, ich weiß es.
Andreas weiß es.
Ja, weil nämlich irgendwie hinterher die Ergebnisse veröffentlicht werden und zwar pro Wahlkreis. Da können also die Wahlhelfer, die in dem Wahlkreis waren, nachgucken, ob in den amtlichen Tabellen ihre Zahl steht und dann die Summe angucken, die unten steht.
Das habe ich sogar gemacht in der Berliner Zeitung. Da habe ich mir alles angeschaut, ob wirklich alles richtig gemeldet wurde.
Das ist schön. Erzähl doch mal ein paar Anekdoten von der Wahl. Also, so Leute, die sich über die Kabinen unterhalten, haben wir gerade schon gehört?
Ja, das waren so ein paar Leute, die hatten nicht so richtig Geduld und haben eben gefragt, ob sie jetzt hinter der Tafel oder so etwas wählen dürften oder vielleicht einfach direkt auf dem Tisch. Und das darfst du dann auch nicht durchgehen lassen. Du müsstest sofort zerstören den Zettel und die müssten nochmal wählen. Und eben immer in einer Kabine. Die dürfen nicht offiziell wählen, du darfst es nicht sehen, was sie wählen. Ansonsten gab es Leute, die für irgendwelche Leute irgendwelche Briefwahlzettel abgegeben haben oder eben verschlossene Briefe. Die konntest du dann nicht öffnen, die musstest du dann liegen lassen und den Wahlamt Bescheid sagen, dass du jetzt hier irgendwelche Briefwähler hattest, die irgendwie, ja und diese Briefe liegen jetzt bei dir. Und die sind schon immer alle fast ausgerastet in diesem Wahlamt, weil die nicht genug Autos hatten, um diese ganzen Briefe dann abzuholen. Da musstest du gucken, wie du diese Briefe irgendwie zum Wahlamt bekommst. Ja, so eine Geschichte nehmen.
Aber erlaubt ist das? Erlaubt ist das, dass man den Briefwahlzettel da direkt im Wahllokal abkriegt?
Ja, also wenn du direkt als Briefwähler kommst, kannst du im Prinzip deine Briefeunterlagen zerstören und kriegst neue Unterlagen zum Wählen. Du stehst ja immer noch in der Wahlliste drin, im Wahlverzeichnis. Und ansonsten kannst du auch mit den geschlossenen Briefen kommen und sagen, so das ist jetzt hier meine Wahl. Im Prinzip müssen wir uns dann darum kümmern, dass die irgendwie zum Wahlamt kommen. Und da war aber in dieser Leute hatten die, von denen das gar nicht direkt die Briefe waren, also die haben zum Beispiel für Kollegen oder Nachbarn oder so was diese Briefe abgegeben, mussten wir uns dann darum kümmern, dass die irgendwie zum Wahlamt kommen. Das war dann ein bisschen heikel. Das war nicht so super. Wie gesagt, die im Wahlamt fanden das auch nicht so richtig lustig.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, macht ihr dann best of ungültige Stimmen? Also wenn da Leute so ganze Romane draufschreiben? Ich meine, das will man doch eigentlich von der Kopie zu Hause haben.
Ja, eigentlich schon. Da gibt es schon so ein paar lustige Sachen. Ich weiß nicht, irgendwelche Leute, die sich dann darüber auslassen, über die Politik im Allgemeinen, auf diesen Wahlzetteln oder, weiß ich nicht, durch neue Parteien ausdenken und die dann irgendwo hinschreiben und die dann ankreuzen oder so was. Da waren schon schöne Sachen dabei. Darüber diskutierst du dann eben mit den ganzen Leuten in deinem Wahllokal. Was gilt noch, was gilt nicht. Es gibt ja auch ganz klare Vorschriften, was darf noch gelten und was nicht. Und wenn jetzt zum Beispiel die Mitte vom Kreuz, genau wo sich die beiden Graden treffen, wenn das jetzt genau gerade noch so irgendwo auf dem Zettel ist und es ist noch gerade so eine Partei zuzuordnen, dann musst du es eigentlich noch gelten lassen. Und dann hast du eben auch eine ganze Weile immer zu tun, um darüber zu diskutieren. Dann fragst du dich auch, warum es Leute nicht hinkriegen, da einfach normal anzukreuzen.
Hast du eine Theorie, warum kriegen die das nicht hin?
Nee, habe ich nicht so richtig. Darüber haben wir lange diskutiert, aber keiner wusste so richtig, warum das nicht möglich sein sollte für einen Menschen.
Dann ist es doch viel schöner, wenn man so eine Maschine hätte und da muss man bloß einen Knopf drücken und der ist dann gedrückt oder nicht gedrückt und dann hat man das Ausziehproblem nicht, oder?
Aber dann kann man keine Romane mehr draufschreiben, oder?
Doch, nur Edding.
Wahlcomputer schränken die Kreativität beim Wählen.
Vielen Dank, Julia.
Gute Nacht, tschüss.
Ja, dir auch noch eine schöne Sendung.
Wo wir gerade bei Wahlcomputern sind, hat der Michael eine Frage.
Michael.
Also, erst mal so vorweg gewählt habe ich auch, obwohl ich natürlich sagen muss, die 41 Prozent nicht fehlen, die sollte man auch nicht so einfach unter den Tisch fallen lassen, die werden wir auch ihren Grund gehabt haben, warum wir nicht gewählt haben.
Ja, mag sein. Es geht um Wahlcomputer.
Und bei den Wahlcomputern, da die Frage, ob denn die Leute vom CTC wissen, gehe ich mal zumindest von aus, wer denn da eigentlich die Firma ist, die diese Geräte herstellt und wie sicher die Geräte achten, was die Manipulierbarkeit angeht.
Genau darauf wollten wir jetzt eigentlich zu sprechen kommen. Gut, dass du das nochmal in die Runde wirst.
Aber gleich mal die andere Frage. Bei diesen Wahlcomputern, da wo sie schon eingesetzt werden, gibt es da eigentlich auch einen Ausdruck für den Wählenden? Kriegt er einen Ausdruck?
Eine Quittung meinst du?
Es gibt da solche und solche.
Nee, es gibt in Deutschland nicht solche und solche.
Es gibt keine Quittung.
Also nix Schrifte hieß?
In Deutschland nicht, nein.
Genau, also ich meine international es gibt solche und solche, aber in Deutschland gibt es halt nur ein Modell.
Ja, bei der Wahlcomputer denkt man ja erstmal naheliegenderweise an Amerika und was da so abgeht. Und diese Firma Diebold, die da hier in der Kritik steht.
Ja genau, also Diebold ist natürlich das, was...
Warum soll das hier in Deutschland besser laufen?
Ja, also die Firma, die sozusagen für Europa, das Diebold ist, das ist die Firma NEDAP. Und das war deine Frage, ne? Dann gehen wir da jetzt gleich mal, sag ich schon mal Tschüss. Vielen Dank für die Frage. Ulrich, jetzt kommen wir im Prinzip mal genau zu dem Thema. Also, welche Wahlcomputersysteme gibt es eigentlich? Welche Firmen spielen da eine Rolle? Und wer war da der erste und wer war da der zweite?
In Deutschland gibt es eigentlich nur einen zugelassenen Anbieter. Das ist die Firma NEDAP, die du eben erwähnt hast. Das ist ein niederländisches Unternehmen und die sind in Niederlanden schon eine ganze Weile unterwegs. In den Niederlanden wird praktisch flächendeckend mit Wahlcomputern gewählt. Und ja, hier ist das wie gesagt Ende der 90er Jahre losgegangen. Wieso kann sich nicht eigentlich jede Gemeinde aussuchen, was für Wahlgeräte sie einsetzen will? Es gibt ein Bundeswahlgesetz, da gibt es ein paar Graf 35, der regelt den Einsatz von Wahlgeräten und Wahlgeräte müssen ein bestimmtes Zulassungsverfahren durchlaufen. Und da findet zunächst eine Geräteprüfung statt durch die Physikalisch-Technische Bundesanstalt. Und wenn die das Gerät für den Richtlinien entsprechend halten, dann wird das anschließend vom Bundesinnenministerium zugelassen. Da gibt es eine Bauartzulassung für das Gerät. Und zusätzlich muss das Gerät noch für jede einzelne Bundestagswahl oder Europawahl zugelassen werden vom Innenminister. Und so eine Bauartzulassung gibt es derzeit in Deutschland nur für dieses eine Gerät, NEDAP.
NEDAP ist die Firma, vielleicht das Gerät.
Wer prüft das Gerät, um dann hinterher eine Zulassung überhaupt möglich zu machen?
Die Physikalisch-Technische Bundesanstalt.
Also da ist davon auszugehen, dass die wissen, was sie tun, oder?
Das ist so ein bisschen eine Sache. Wie die PTB dazu kommt, das ist eher so ein Unfall der Geschichte, weil es schon in den späten 70ern mechanische Wahlmaschinen gab. Und die PTB sind halt Physiker, sind vielleicht bekannt durch Funkuhrn. Also das Signal für die Funkuhr wird von der PTB ausgestrahlt zum Beispiel. Haben dann halt aus historischen Gründen auch den anderen Kram geerbt und kennen sich aber eigentlich mit Computern nicht so wirklich aus, muss man sagen. Das Wahlgesetz, also das entsprechende Paragrafenwerk, das vorschreibt, wie so eine Wahlmaschine auszusehen hat, so ein mittlerweile auch Wahlcomputer, das enthält leider nicht besonders viele Vorschriften darüber, wie das mit der Sicherheit funktionieren soll. Also da sind Sicherheit in Deutsch immer so ein Wort, was im Englischen zwei Bedeutungen hat, Safety und Security. Und es geht einmal darum, dass es das tut, was es tun soll. Und zum anderen darum, dass man nicht dafür sorgen kann, dass es etwas anderes tut, was zwei Paar Schuhe sind. Also die Zuverlässigkeit gegen die Manipulationssicherheit. Und das mit der Zuverlässigkeit, das bekommen sie ziemlich gut hin. Also diese, die Überprüfung ob denn irgendwie die Wahl auch, also sie gucken sich den Source Code an, ob das dem Wahlgesetz entspricht von der Rechenweise her. Und ob das Ding ordentlich geerdet ist, nicht kaputt geht, wenn es runterfällt. Und beim Stimmen wegschreiben ins Flash, wenn dann mal irgendwo in Kontakt korreliert ist, nichts passiert. Und wenn mal der Strom ausfällt, dass die Stimme nicht verloren geht. Also sowas ist schon relativ gut geprüft. Wovon die PTB halt überhaupt gar keine Ahnung hat, ist Computersicherheit. Und dementsprechend ist auch der Prüfbericht ausgefallen. Also sie schreiben, dass es keine expliziten Vorschriften gibt, um die Sicherheit zu prüfen, dass sie deswegen implizit die Sicherheit sich mal angeguckt haben, was eine sehr vage Aussage ist. Und im Prüfbericht steht dann nahezu wörtlich, Gerät ist sicher gegen Manipulation, Doppelpunkt. Dann ist da so ein Kästchen mit einem Haken und es steht OK dann. Also das ist der vollständige Text der Prüfung zum Thema Sicherheit dieser Geräte bei der PTB.
Also ist sicher, weil ist so.
Weil muss so.
Weil muss so. Es gibt eine etwas ausführlichere Stellungnahme des Innenministeriums. Nachdem der Ulrich Widerspruch eingelegt hat, hat das Innenministerium sich bemüßigt gesehen, zu dem Thema mal Stellung zu nehmen.
Das haben wir noch gar nicht so in Detail besprochen, wie du Widerspruch eingelegt hast, oder?
Wir hatten das glaube ich kurz erwähnt.
Kurz erwähnt, eben.
Soll ich das kurz erzählen?
Fände ich ganz hübsch, wenn du das mal komplett rekapitulieren könntest, bevor wir hier so weit vorgreifen.
Okay, es gibt in Deutschland eigentlich keine andere Möglichkeit, gegen Wahlfehler oder gegen Unregelmäßigkeiten bei Wahlen vorzugehen, als nachdem der Fehler passiert ist, Einspruch einzulegen gegen das Ergebnis. Dann findet eine Wahlprüfung statt durch den Bundestag. Da gibt es einen Wahlprüfungsausschuss, der da eine Beschlussvorlage vorbereitet.
Setzt sich zusammen aus Abgeordneten aller Parteien?
Ja, setzt sich zusammen aus Abgeordneten aller Parteien nach bestimmten Schlüsseln. Da gibt es dann für jeden Einspruch einen Berichterstatter, der bereitet diese Entscheidung vor, zusammen mit so einem wissenschaftlichen Stab. Und dann stimmt der Bundestag darüber ab. Und dann haben die betroffenen Abgeordneten oder auch der jeweilige einsprechende Anschleiß schließend, wenn sie mit der Entscheidung des Bundestages nicht zufrieden sind, die Möglichkeit, dagegen Beschwerde beim Bundesverfassungsgericht einzuleiten.
Das ist aber dann noch der alte Bundestag, ne? Also nicht die neu gewählten, sondern...
Nee, der neue Bundestag.
Der stimmt selber darüber ab, ob seine Wahl zulässig war, sozusagen.
Genau, das ist historisch begründet.
Es ist rechtens, dass ich diesen Job jetzt habe.
Also die Wahlprüfung durch das Parlament hat seinen historischen Ursprung eigentlich in Großbritannien und war damals im 17. Jahrhundert ein Schutz vor königlicher Willkür. Und das haben dann die Franzosen nach der Französischen Revolution übernommen. Und die Deutschen haben es Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts da abgeschrieben. In der Weimarer Republik war das mal anders. Da gab es mal ein Wahlprüfungsgericht. Aber in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik hat man das halt wieder so gemacht. Als die Deutschen bei den Englern dann abgeschrieben haben, dieses Konzept, da haben die Engländer das schon längst nicht mehr gemacht. In England gibt es nämlich auch ein Wahlprüfungsgericht, in dem keine Parlamentarier sitzen. Also ein interessantes Verfahren, weil das natürlich dem Rechtsstaatsprinzip nicht so richtig entspricht. Kann man da was gegen tun?
Das kann nur das Parlament was gegen tun, dass es sich selbst nicht mehr prüft.
Das Wahlprüfungsrecht ist verankert im Grundgesetz. Da ist ausdrücklich die Wahlprüfung durch den Bundestag festgelegt. Da können wir jetzt sagen...
Und der Bundestag weiß warum.
Das wird durchaus kritisch diskutiert. Da gab es auch mal Ende der 90er-Jahre einen Ausschuss zur Entlastung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts. Die haben sich mit sowas auch beschäftigt und empfohlen, das einem Wahlprüfungsgericht zu übertragen. Das ist ein sehr schwerfälliges Verfahren. Bei der letzten Bundestagswahl gab es etwa 190 Einsprüche. Von denen sind derzeit etwa 110 abgelehnt. Die restlichen 80 sind noch offen.
Und deiner?
Meiner ist auch noch offen.
Wogegen genau hast du Einspruch eingelegt?
Ich hab Einspruch eingelegt gegen den Einsatz der Wahlcomputer wegen Verletzung des Öffentlichkeitsprinzips bei den Wahlen.
Das Öffentlichkeitsprinzip ist was?
Das Öffentlichkeitsprinzip ist ein Wahlrechtsgrundsatz, der über die Grundsätze hinaus, die der Andreas vorhin erläutert hat, sicherstellt, dass diese primären Grundsätze eingehalten werden. Also demokratische Wahlen sind frei und... Freigeheim und gleich sein. Und das wird sichergestellt dadurch, dass der Prozess öffentlich ist. Und dann gibt es noch ein weiteres Prinzip, was sicherstellt, dass Wahlen verifizierbar sind. Also, dass ich hinterher noch mal nachzählen kann. Und das sind eigentlich zwei Prinzipien, die bei den Wahlcomputern zumindest stark gefährdet sind. Denn so ein Wahlcomputer ist eine Black Box. Man kann ja den Elektronen da nicht mit dem Auge folgen. Und man bringt praktisch seine Stimme nicht mehr mit dem Ergebnis zusammen. Ich kann nicht wie bei einer Stimmzettelwahl wirklich nachverfolgen, dass meine Stimme auch in der Ohne landet. Das kann so sein, kann aber auch nicht so sein. Aus technischer Sicht ist es natürlich relativ einfach, einen Computer zu bauen, der Stimmen richtig zählt. Aber es ist auch genauso einfach, einen Computer zu bauen, der die Stimme nicht richtig zählt. Und als Wähler oder auch als Wahlhelfer oder als Wahlprüfer kann ich das nicht unterscheiden.
Die Musik ist langweilig. Es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat, hier ist das Chaos Radio Folge 117, Wahlcomputer unser Thema. So, und während Tim neue Musik auswählt, telefoniere ich... Ja bitte, das hätte ich jetzt nicht auszahlen. Ist ja fast so schlimm, als würdest du hier Gitarrenmusik spielen.
Immer ich.
Ich hab hier einen Mix, der heißt Fluftig. Klingt das nach was?
Fluftig?
Ja, ist von der Frau.
Ich wechsle mal hier um.
Ja, wechsle mal den Mix. Ich geh solange ans Telefon. 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Nummer. Und der Axel hat angerufen.
Hallo?
Axel, du warst da, wo die Zulassungen für Wahlgeräte getätigt wurden.
Mitte der 90er Jahre, als es noch um mechanische Wahlgeräte ging, war ich in der Abteilung der Physikalischen und Technischen Bundesanstalt, die hier in Berlin sitzt und die sich mit Spielgeräten und Wahlgeräten befasst.
Ach so, die nehmen auch einarmige Banditen und Wahlmaschinen.
Einarmige Banditen sind in Deutschland so nicht zugelassen. Aber im Prinzip ja, also Geldspielgeräte. Alles, was Geldspiel ist, ist gesetzlich verboten. Ausnahme regelt die Spielordnung und aus historischen Gründen sind tatsächlich diese beiden, naja, nicht ganz so zusammengehenden Fachgebiete mal zusammengelegt worden. Also Wahlgeräte und Geldspielgeräte.
Was für Wahlgeräte waren das denn? Mechanische.
Das war also so richtig, so ähnlich wie das HSG-Teil heute auch funktioniert, dass man also der Wahlleiter, der die Stimmeabgabe dort kontrolliert, einen Schlüssel gedreht hat und man hat dann mechanisch eine Taste bedient, eine relativ große übrigens, damals. Und es gab da auch die Möglichkeit noch Korrekturen, man konnte ja irgendwie eine falsche Taste erwischen oder so. Und final abgeschlossen hat man es dann mit einem zweiten Tastendruck, dass es dann die Stimme gezählt wurde.
Ist das je zum Einsatz gekommen?
Nein, ich weiß nicht. Zumindest nicht in Deutschland. Man hat es wohl immer versucht, aber es ist wohl nie dazu gekommen. Ich weiß nicht mal, ob es wirklich zugelassen worden ist. Ich habe mehrere Bauarten gesehen. Ich weiß, dass man mit denen richtig großen Aufwand getrieben hat. Insbesondere bezüglich EMV-Verträglichkeit und so. Man ist da irgendwie mit einem Elektroschocker drauf losgegangen. Nicht, dass man irgendwie mit dem Teil irgendwie es schafft, alle bisher abgegebenen Stimmen beispielsweise zu löschen oder so.
Also es gibt tatsächlich in Hessen und im Saarland noch einige, ganz wenige Gemeinden, die mit solchen Zigarettenautomaten artigen Geräten wählen.
Zigarettenautomat ist kein schlechter Vergleich.
Du drückst einen dicken Knopf rein und dann fällt unten eine Partei raus.
Ja, so was in der Art. Genau.
Und die kannst du in der Pfeife rauchen.
Merkel-Ultra.
Ich weiß heutzutage, da man hin und wieder ja nochmal mit den alten Kollegen spricht, es gibt jetzt einen großen Anforderungskatalog, den die PTB erstellt hat in Berlin. Es gibt extra eine Fachabteilung oder ein Projekt dafür, was sich jetzt mit Anforderungskatalog für Onlinewahlsysteme befasst. Und da gibt es auch einen relativ umfangreichen Bericht. Allerdings schließt der beispielsweise komplett irgendwelche Sachen bei der Produktion aus. Man kann also irgendwie nicht nachprüfen. Also zumindest steht in diesem Anforderungskatalog dazu nicht. Ich weiß allerdings nicht, ob das eventuell gar nicht Ziel des Anforderungskatalogs war. Dass ich beispielsweise sicherstellen kann, dass irgendein netter, frustrierter Mitarbeiter irgendeinen netten Bug einbaut, mit dem er dann durch eine geniale Tastenkombination oder ähnliches das Gerät manipulieren kann. Woher hatten übrigens die Leute der Geldspielgeräte auch immer Angst, dass irgendein frustrierter Software-Mitarbeiter irgendwie dem Gerät eine Tastenkombination beibringt, mit dem man das Gerät dann hinreichend bescheißen kann.
Wie ist das mit deinen Kollegen von der PTB oder auch mit dir? Würdest du einer solchen Wahl trauen?
Nicht so richtig.
Und deine Kollegen, was sagen die?
Die sagen, im Rahmen unserer technischen Möglichkeiten haben wir es geprüft. Es gibt ja bei der PTB einen Bereich Softwarequalitätssicherung. Und man befasst sich da auch recht umfangreich mit solchen Anforderungen, auch mit Quercode-Analysen in verschiedenen Formen. Und soweit wie ich weiß, läuft das wohl auch in Zusammenarbeit mit dem BSI. Aber natürlich ist das Grundproblem dieser Wahl trotz allem immer noch nicht behoben. Nach dem Motto, es steht zwar drin, man muss also, der Anforderungskatalog beschreibt ja noch kein Gerät, der beschreibt ja erstmal nur die Anforderungen, die ich an das Gerät stelle. Und da steht dann auch, dass es also technische Möglichkeiten geben muss, um beispielsweise die abgegebenen Stimmen für fünf Jahre archivieren zu können. Und dass ich Hard- und Software dazu haben muss, um die auch nach fünf Jahren noch auslesen zu können. Und dass ich auch beispielsweise jeden Zugriff protokollieren muss auf diese Archive. Und dass die nachfolgende Auslese, Hard- und Softwarekombination, wie sie auch immer aussieht, auch so gestaltet werden muss, dass sie definitiv keine Veränderungen in dem Protokoll ablaufen lassen darf. Aber wie gesagt, das sind natürlich alles nette Wunschträume.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, selbst für mich als Lion klingt das wie ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass das geht.
100%ige Sicherheit wird es nie geben. Aber die 100%ige Sicherheit, glaube ich, gibt es in der Zettelversion auch nicht. Wie wir vorhin gefunden haben, sicherlich ist der Weg dorthin sehr schwierig. Aber wir malen mal irgendwie schwarzen Teufel an die Wand in einem finstern bayerischen Bergdorf, wo sich alle kennen. Könnte ich mir das vorstellen, dass genügend Leute mitspielen und sagen, hier ohne mich. Wäre eine ganz finstere Vermutung.
Aber immerhin wäre das dann immer noch für jemanden wie mich nachvollziehbar. Ich könnte da immer noch hin pilgern, könnte mir immer noch den Ordner aus dem Regal nehmen und könnte diese Stimmen händisch nachzählen. Wenn da irgendein schwarzer Kasten steht, den ich noch nicht mal zu bedienen weiß, dann weiß ich das dem auch nicht mehr zu prüfen.
Ich sage ja auch nicht, dass ich also unbedingt der Sache so richtig zustimmen kann. Ich finde die Idee auch nicht so toll, weil es also tatsächlich diverse Möglichkeiten eröffnet, die man vermutlich von vornherein nicht alle auszesten kann. Denn irgendwie ist es bisher ja wohl relativ unmöglich, in der Software zu schreiben, die 100% sicher funktioniert. Das einzige System, wie ich mir einen Wahlrechner vorstellen könnte, wäre so wie die ersten Computer, die für Volkszählungen verwendet worden sind, funktionieren könnten. Dass sozusagen pro abgegebene Stimme hinten so eine Karte rausfällt.
So ein Lockkartensystem.
Und die Lockkarten kann ich dann wieder in den Schrank legen. Da habe ich wieder Karten. Da sind ja bloß keine Kreuze drauf, sondern halt Karten.
Axel, jetzt kommen wir aber im Prinzip genauer an den Kernpunkt, an den wir eigentlich auch ansetzen wollen. Zunächst einmal muss man sich wirklich fragen, was ist eigentlich überhaupt das Problem? Wozu braucht man eigentlich eine Wahlmaschine und wozu braucht man eigentlich einen Wahlcomputer? Weil wir stellen im Allgemeinen fest, alles was wir bisher gehört haben. Bisher könnte man auch mit Zetteln wählen. Der Großteil aller Wahlen überall wird immer noch so gemacht. Alle Leute, die jetzt Wahlhelfer waren, meinen, ich habe den Prozess vollkommen nachvollziehen können. Es gab gegenseitige Kontrolle. Eine Betrug kann weitgehend ausgeschlossen werden. Und du meinst halt so, wenn es irgendwo klappt, dann halt an so einem verschworenen Bergdorf, wo wahrscheinlich sowieso alle nur irgendwie das gleiche wählen.
Sowieso alle von vornherein auf dasselbe wählen, weil der Fahrer dasselbe sagt.
Und selbst da wäre es sozusagen möglich, wenn man Verdacht hat, dann einfach noch jemand dazu zu schicken. Und das ist eben genauer der Punkt. Wir haben also einfach eine umfangreiche Überprüfbarkeit des gesamten Wahlvorgangs. Und man fragt sich, was ist eigentlich das Problem? Vorhin haben wir noch mal darüber gesprochen. Was sind denn eigentlich so die Gründe, warum sich jetzt so eine Kommune so ein Gerät zulegen muss? Weil das kostet ja auch Geld, so. Okay, Wahlen kosten auch Geld, weil man braucht Wahlhelfer. Ja, es ist eine gewisse Organisation und Wahllokal und so weiter. Aber vieles davon kann man sich auch mit diesen Geräten nicht sparen. Und jeder, der schon mal so mit Computerprojekten was zu tun gehabt hat, weiß, da sind auch so versteckte Kosten in der Zukunft. Weil eben solche Geräte eine unglaubliche Komplexität mit sich bringen. Die man am Anfang vielleicht auch gar nicht so sieht oder dann auch vielleicht vorsätzlich gar nicht einpreist, weil klingt dann irgendwie erst mal billiger. Das heißt, der einzige Vorteil, den man so gewinnen kann, wäre, dass die Wahl schneller ausgezählt wird. Aber mein Gott, was ist denn bitte eine Stunde oder acht Stunden im Extremfall, wo mal so ein Wahllokal ausgezählt wird?
Ein spannender Fernsehabend.
Ja, okay, ein spannender Fernsehabend. Aber das muss es uns meiner Meinung nach auch wert sein. Aber eins wollte ich noch mal vorwegbringen, und das bringst du ganz gut auch schon in den Punkt. Die Computer bringen eine... Also, die Papiervariante ist auch bescheißbar. Aber im schlimmsten Fall hast du einen Betrugsausschlag, der extrem regional begrenzt ist. Während bei Computersystemen, in dem Moment, wo man das Ganze automatisierbar macht und damit sozusagen auch einfach auf andere regionale Bereiche übertragen kann, hat man sofort mit einem globalen Problem zu tun. In dem Moment, wo man global Auswirkungen auf eine Wahl beeinflussen kann, hat man es mit einer ganz anderen Problematik zu tun, als dass jetzt irgendein Bergdorf ausschert.
Ja, das ist richtig. Wenn das System fehlerhaft ist, ist es überall fehlerhaft. Das spricht an jedem Einsatzort.
Und vor allem nicht nachvollziehbar.
Du redest viel von fehlerhaft. Ich denke, dass irgendwie ein großes Problem, das ich bei den Prüfergebnissen der PTB sehe, ist einfach dieser Blickwinkel auf das Gerät, muss zuverlässig funktionieren. Und weniger der Blickwinkel auf das Gerät muss manipulationssicher sein. Also wenn man sich das anguckt, so eine NEDAP-Maschine, die speichert die Stimmen halt auf zwei verschiedenen EPROMs. Wenn eins kaputt geht, ist immer noch das andere da. Speichert die Stimme einmal normal und einmal invertiert, sodass wenn ein Bit kaputt geht, man das trotzdem noch rekonstruieren kann, mit Checksum und allem drum dran. Also wirklich toll, wirklich wunderbar. Aber irgendwie in dem Prüfbericht, der mittlerweile verfügbar ist, habe ich halt so Sachen vermisst wie überhaupt eine Attack Tree-Analyse, eine Risiko-Analyse, überhaupt eine Einschätzung dazu, wo man manipulieren kann, was man manipulieren kann, wie schwierig das zu manipulieren ist. Und also bis hin zu so Schoten wie Überprüfung, ob denn das Binary, das getestet wurde, auch dem Source Code entspricht, der geoutet wurde, fand nicht statt, sondern der Hersteller hat glaubhaft versichert, dass diese Sourcen zu dem Binary geführt haben. Und das ist halt, da glaube ich auch nicht, dass es BSI gefragt wurde, weil die wissen sowas. Und das kommt mir halt so ein bisschen merkwürdig vor.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Ich habe wie gesagt bei dem letzten leider auch nicht mehr irgendwie dort gearbeitet, weiß also da nicht genau, was da wirklich abgelaufen ist. Es wundert mich eigentlich ein bisschen, weil wie gesagt, ich habe in Erinnerung, wie man mit was für einem doch sehr großen Aufwand man zu Zeiten dieses elektromechanischen, also rein mechanisch war das ja auch nicht, dieses elektromechanischen Wahlgerätes versucht hat, irgendwie zumindest auch die Funktionssicherheit zu testen. Und heutzutage würde das ja eigentlich dazu gehören. Da bin ich dann auch sehr erstaunt darüber.
Hast du deine Kollegen mal gefragt, warum das nicht geschieht?
Nein, habe ich nicht. Ich habe leider erst heute gelesen, dass das überhaupt stattfindet und habe da irgendwie keinen mehr erreicht. Also ich bin neben dem Blumen und Stapfel nicht. Ich habe da keinen erreicht.
Wir wären ja glaube ich sehr verbunden, wenn du das mal in Nachholz bei Gelingerti zu fragen und vielleicht sogar einen Kontakt zu uns herstellen würdest.
Ja, das können wir machen. Sicher. Ich kann nochmal anrufen. Sollte nicht die Frage sein.
Wir haben noch einen Anrufer, den Alex. Da geht es auch um Sicherheit.
Alex, mit los. Ich bin sicherlich auch nicht von der Sache überzeugt. Ich finde das auch relativ alles erschreckend. Ich habe in letzter Zeit die Berichte dazu gelesen. Ich habe auch die Berichte zu Diebold gelesen. Das fand ich auch recht erschreckend. Nun aber mal die andere Frage. Sicherlich redet man ja viel darüber, aber es geschieht trotzdem. Ob RSID, ob sonst irgendwas, es passiert ja, oder?
Naja, es sei denn man stoppt es.
Ja gut, okay, also das ist vieles, wo das versucht und so weiter. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sich das, wie auch in vielen anderen Ländern, leider durchsetzen wird.
Das ist nicht unbedingt so in allen Ländern so. Es gibt da einen sehr populären Fall. Das erste Land war das erste Land. Irland fand das mal ganz toll. Die haben sich gedacht, super Wahlcomputer und so die Zukunft. Es gibt ja auch dieses Modernitätsargument. Die Dinge sind gut, weil sie modern sind. Ulrich, kannst du mal kurz ausführen, was da genau passiert ist in Irland?
Die Republik Irland hat vor einigen Jahren für das komplette Land diese NEDAP-Wahlgeräte angeschafft. Weil das nicht so schleichend gelaufen ist, wie hier in Deutschland, Kommune für Kommune, gab es da auch ein ordentliches Medienecho. Und eine große öffentliche Debatte. Und die irische Regierung hat sich dann genötigt gesehen, eine Kommission einzusetzen, die die Sicherheit dieser Geräte bewerten sollte. Und die sind dann zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass sie den Einsatz der Geräte nicht empfehlen können. Und die hatten da also einige Sachen anzumeckern. Zum Beispiel, dass die Überprüfbarkeit des Ergebnisses nicht gewährleistet ist. Dass der Wähler nicht überprüfen kann, ob seine Stimme tatsächlich ankommt. Die haben erhebliche Sicherheitsmängel angebracht zu den Geräten.
Entschuldigung, das interessiert doch in Deutschland hier nicht wirklich ein. Das ist ein Problem von Deutschland. Das mag in Ländern funktionieren, wo die Bürger noch entscheiden, in der Schweiz, in Irland, in kleinen Kommunen oder in Deutschland.
Hier entscheiden auch die Bürger.
Worauf ich ja hinaus wollte, ist im Endeffekt ja auch dieses Komitee was überprüft. Ich meine im Endeffekt, die Frage wäre ja, ist es technisch machbar oder durch Open Source so realisierbar, dass eine Transparenz vorhanden ist, die es durchaus vielleicht ermöglicht, eine Stimmenabgabe online oder digital zu machen, wo jeder auch sagen kann, okay, das kann ich nachvollziehen, das kann ich einsehen, weiß ich zur Not, fliegt hinten die Logkarte raus.
Die Frage, wie sähe eine sichere Maschine aus?
Genau, wie sähe eine Maschine aus. Heute vertrauen ja auch die Banken auf SSL oder SSH und gehen in der Annahme, dass es sicher ist. Und was sollen sie anders tun? Ich meine, sie haben nur das.
Nee, die Banken gehen nicht davon aus, dass es sicher ist, sondern die Banken gehen davon aus, es gibt da diesen schönen Begriff der rentablen Sicherheit. Für die ist es sicher genug, wenn es billiger ist, das so zu tun, es unsicher quasi durchzuführen, als den entsprechenden Aufwand zu leisten, um es noch sicherer zu machen. Das ist sozusagen der wirtschaftliche Ansatz. Den dürfen wir allerdings auf demokratischen Ebene, meiner Auffassung nach, überhaupt nicht heranziehen.
Die Fehlerquote muss unter dem liegen, als man mit Papierzetteln bescheißen könnte. Wenn man mit Papierzetteln mehr bescheißen kann, als zum Schluss dann noch mit dem Computer, dann wäre es okay. Dann hätte man ja das Ding auch noch geknackt.
Das Problem ist, dass diese Nachvollziehbarkeit halt nur für Spezialisten gegeben ist. Wir haben ja eben gehört, dass ganz normale Leute sagen irgendwie, hey, mir liegt was in dieser Demokratie, ich gehe mal Wahlhilfe machen, gucken sich das an und sagen hinterher, ich bin mir sicher, ich bin überzeugt davon, dass die Wahl in Ordnung war. Und die Anzahl Leute, selbst wenn das alles Open Source ist, die Anzahl der Leute, die wirklich überprüfen können, dass die Maschine hinterher das tut, was du denkst, dass es tut, die ist einfach mal verschwindend gering. Und sicherlich könnte man mehr machen, als bei den heutigen Geräten getan wird. Sicherlich gibt es kryptographische Protokolle, die eine anonyme, aber trotzdem nachvollziehbare Stimmabgabe übers Internet ermöglichen. Aber auch Onlinewahlen sind ein bisschen seltsames Problem, weil dann sitzt man zu Hause und dann irgendwie... Das ist nicht mehr der richtige Wahlgang, Herr, natürlich. Ja, dann sagt irgendwie der Mann zur Frau, du willst sie aber CDU, genau, klick mal da. Und das ist halt auch nicht der gewünschte Effekt. Also ich denke, dass die, also einfach keine Veranlassung besteht, überhaupt auf Papier und Zettel zu verzichten, weil das, was man dabei gewinnt, so gering ist, dass es sich nicht lohnt, dafür dieses hohe Risiko einzugeben, dass die Wahlen plötzlich nicht mehr für jedermann nachvollziehbar sind, sondern für eine Handvoll ausgewählter Spezialisten.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist auch meine Meinung, aber ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht daran, dass das so zu stoppen ist, zumal es sich halt sehr schleichend und es gibt ja keinen Aufschrei oder es gibt ja kein so oh, der Computer hat falsch gezählt oder so und jetzt geht das durch die Medien und dann haben alle Angst vor oder so.
Warum nicht? Also wir fangen jetzt gerade an. Wenn du mitmachst, sind wir schon zwei, vier, fünf.
Ja gut, wenn man da nur noch einen Schlüssel drauf hat, der Hausbauer vom Hotel oder so, um die Demokratie zu verändern, dann sicherlich ist es.
Ja gut, dein Pessimismus in allen Ehren, das kannst du natürlich machen, wie du willst, aber wir teilen diesen Pessimismus nicht, sondern wir sehen das einfach mal ganz anders. Das Hauptproblem ist, und das haben wir ja hier auch schon in den Reaktionen gemerkt, die meisten Leute wissen überhaupt gar nicht, dass diese Systeme überhaupt schon im Einsatz sind. Man hört immer so ein bisschen was von den USA, aber dass das hier wirklich tatsächlich quasi vorangeht und dass es einige europäische Länder gibt, die das eben schon tun, das ist ein anderer Fall. Aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass es zurückzudrehen ist, denn es ist ja für alle von Nachteil. Es gibt überhaupt niemanden, der davon einen Vorteil hat, außer vielleicht den Firmen, die das herstellen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Lobby genug haben. Das ist im Wesentlichen ein mittelständisches Unternehmen in Holland. Und das ist nicht unbedingt Lobby genug, um sich gegen 80 Millionen Deutsche durchzusetzen, meiner Auffassung nach. Ja, in deine Ohren auf jeden Fall und die anderen natürlich auch. Weil es gibt einfach ein paar ganz grundsätzliche Probleme. Und ich denke, das sollten wir jetzt auch hier noch mal festhalten, was diese Probleme sind.
Stopp mal kurz. Alex, erstens danke für deinen Anruf.
Ich danke auch immer wieder gerne.
Tschüss, gute Nacht. Zweitens, sprich doch mit jemandem, der es live gesehen hat. Hallo Robert. Du warst in Cottbus Wahlhelfer bei einem elektronischen Wahlverfahren.
Ja, genau.
Ich glaube, Tim würde sich gerne mit dir unterhalten.
Ja, wir alle. Ja, ich war halt auch, weil ich davon gesagt habe, in einem Bergdorf, es war halt auch so eine ländliche, so eingemeinete Geschichte. Und also ich denke auch, dass, wenn da nicht so viel Andrang ist oder so, dass man da durchaus, sag ich mal, wenn die Leute sich da verstehen oder so, man unterhält sich ja da auch und so weiter, dass es da Möglichkeiten gibt. Aber das kann man ja, wenn der Papier war, sicherlich auch machen.
Wie war der Ablauf bei euch? Also ich komme dahin, gebe meine Wahlbenachrichtigungen ab und kriege dann von dir so eine kleine Münze mit einem Loch in der Mitte, was ich die Maschine werfe und darf dann einmal abstimmen, oder?
Ja, nee, es geht dann halt so, dass man halt drückt. Statt ins Kreuz zu machen und da sitzt halt immer, das ist halt das Ding, dass da immer einer sitzt und die Stimmen freigabend drückt. Also statt einen Zettel daraus zu rücken, wird halt pro Person immer nur einmal gedrückt. Und wenn er abgestimmt hat, ist das erledigt eigentlich. Dann muss er gehen und ich könnte jetzt rein theoretisch, wenn ich den kenne oder der dahinter geht, die Wahlkabine, könnte ich jetzt nochmal freigabend drücken und nochmal, nochmal, nochmal. Dann hat er halt mehrere Stimmen.
Okay, aber dann stimmt natürlich die Gesamtanzahl nicht mehr mit dem überein, was man in der Liste abgestrichen hat.
Das ist richtig, aber das kann man ja mit den Lichtwählern irgendwie halt korrigieren, aber das wäre eine krasse Möglichkeit.
Aber fangen wir vielleicht mal ganz vorne an.
Ich habe noch eine Frage. Das heißt, du wärst aber auch als Einzelner in der Lage, das zu machen?
Nee, als Einzelner nicht, weil es sind ja immer drei, vier Leute, die Wahlhelfer sind da und die gehen ja davon aus, dass die sich untereinander halt auch ein bisschen kontrollieren und da halt gucken, was der Einzelne macht.
Das heißt auch, jemand anders streicht die Liste ab als derjenige, der die Freigabe drückt?
Ja, richtig. Jedes Mal, wenn einer gedrückt, also in einer Gewitter wird er ja abgestrichen, logisch.
Aber drückt derjenige auf Freigabe, der auch die Liste abhakt?
Nee, das sind dann immer die anderen. Das ist dann alles geteilt. Und am Ende wird das ja auch ausgedruckt. Also da kommt ja dann echt ein Bom. Wir haben das Ding dann zugeklappt und die dreht dann den Schlüssel. Die hat dann so die Wahlleiterin, die hat dann den Schlüssel.
Am Ende des Wahltages.
Genau, und dann wird das ja alles, und dann heftet die das alles ab und fährt dann mit zum Wahlbüro. Also insofern, da stehen ja auch die gesamten...
Also da haben dann, wie viele Leute haben da gewählt an dem Tag? Ungefähr? Du meintest, es wäre kleine? Okay, also 500 Leute kommen an und drücken auf den Knopf. Und am Schluss dreht dann einer in der Kurbel und dann macht es Katsching und dann kommt da irgendwie das Ergebnis bei raus. Aber es gab keinen Zettel für die Leute, also für die einzelnen, jede einzelne Wahl steht ausschließlich in diesem Computer drin. Genau, und woher weißt du, dass die Zahl, die da rauskam, auch tatsächlich den Stimmen entsprochen hat, die die Leute da eingegeben haben?
Okay, also im Gegensatz zu den anderen Wahlhelfern, die vorhin gesagt haben, sie können ausschließen, dass da manipuliert wurde, sagst du, du hast da zwar zugeguckt, aber ob das Ergebnis stimmt, weißt du nicht?
Na ja, sofern das Geräte nicht jetzt irgendwie...
Ja oder nein, ist das Gerät manipuliert gewesen? Du weißt es nicht.
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass der Ausdruck so...
Das stimmt halt. Das stimmt schon so. Okay, aber wenn ich jetzt sage, ich war den Tag vorher da und bin da in Keller gestiegen und habe da eine andere Software reingetan und die hat die Stimme ein bisschen verändert, das hätte sie nicht mitgekriegt, oder?
Nee, natürlich nicht. Ja, die bringen die Dinge ja auch an. Ich weiß nicht, wo die vorher rumliegen.
Genau. Wie ist das eigentlich vom Ablauf? Warst du da von Anfang an dabei? Also wir haben ja vorhin gehört, bei einer normalen Wahl bei einer normalen Wahl gibt es dann so eine leere Box, die dann aufgestellt wird. Die bringen die Maschinen morgens, oder?
Also ich kam halt ein bisschen später, da stand das Ding, da haben sie es gerade aufgebaut. Ich weiß nicht, woher das kam und so.
Okay, warst du dabei, als es in Betrieb genommen wurde?
Ja, das haben wir alle da angeschlossen, da mussten wir uns auch erstmal durchfetzen.
Gab es da so ein Protokoll, wo dann eine Check-Summe auf dem Display angezeigt wurde, die hinten mit dem Aufkleber verglichen wurde auf dem Gerät? Hast du das mitbekommen? Weiß nicht mehr genau, okay.
Check ist nö, aber an sich, also wie gesagt, wenn man jetzt groß und ganz davon ausgeht, dass da jetzt kein Spezialist, kein Hacker oder so dann da rumfummelt, dann denk ich mal, ist das okay soweit.
Ja, aber wie kannst du davon ausgehen? Du hast ja keine Leitindizien.
Keine Ahnung, ne, das ist richtig. Oder dann kann ich auch verstehen, dass du da irgendwie Einspruch geben.
Reicht dir das denn, Robert, davon ausgehen zu können, dass es möglicherweise nicht manipuliert ist? Reicht dir das jetzt im demokratischen Sinne?
Nö, also würde ich schon sichergehen auf jeden Fall. Also insofern finde ich die Dinge natürlich auch überflüssig klar. Also total ist eigentlich auch total öde da den ganzen Tag immer dieses Knöpfchen zu drücken.
Dann fang mal ganz abgesehen.
Der Spaß geht verloren.
Auf jeden Fall, und was sie auch gesagt haben mit der Kreativität und so.
Ich meine, beunruhigt dich das so ein bisschen oder bist du so der Meinung, das hat schon alles seine Richtigkeit?
Naja, fest beunruhigen, also ich... Könnte jetzt jeder gegen Einspruch erheben auch, ne? Zum Beispiel? Ich hab mich ja halt eher darüber aufgeregt, dass man jetzt so leicht manipulieren könnte, aber das war jetzt diese Bergdorf-Geschichte. Da hab ich mir eher einen Kopf gemacht.
Na gut, aber das Problem hast du sozusagen immer. Das ist aber auch in dem Moment, wo man so ein Wahllokal oder so ein Wahlbezirk als Problembereich erkennt.
Nee, das relativiert sich auch.
Also ich glaube, der entscheidende Unterschied, was die Möglichkeit von Manipulationen angeht, ist, dass wenn ich bei Stimmzettelwahlen großflächig manipulieren will, da brauch ich eine Vielzahl von Mitwissern. Das kann ich nicht mit zwei, drei Leuten machen. Aber wenn ich das irgendwie schaffe, bei so einem Wahlcomputer an der zentralen Stelle, bevor die verteilt werden, die Software zu ändern, dann kann ich mit ganz wenigen Leuten ganz, ganz viel verschieben.
Ich wollte da nochmal auf ein anderes Argument zu sprechen kommen, was vorhin noch bei dem Anrufer da war. Da war nämlich so diese Aussage, und das ist ja auch sehr verbreitet. Wir haben ja auch viele Diskussionen geführt bei uns im Club. Man hat natürlich auch so ein bisschen diesen Hang zu, na ja, mehr Demokratiewagen und die Fähigkeiten der modernen Medien und das Internet. Wir sind ja eigentlich auch nochmal sehr zukunftsoptimistisch in gewisser Hinsicht. Und dann kommt dann irgendwann auch dieses Argument, na ja, vielleicht kriegt man diese Computer ja sicher, wenn es Open Source ist. Nach dem Motto, Open Source ist für so viel ist ja auch eine gute Lösung. Vielleicht ist das ja hier auch die Sache. Weil wenn ich ja einsehen kann, was das Programm tut, dann kann ich mir ja sicher sein, dass es richtig funktioniert. Das ist natürlich in so fern richtig, als dass, wenn man das jetzt vergleicht mit den Produkten von den Herstellern, wie man sie heute auf dem Markt hat, die eben nicht Open Source sind, das heißt der Programmcode wird bei denen geschrieben, tut dann irgendwas und kommt in so binär Variante auf dieses Gerät und läuft dann einfach. Dann weiß man natürlich schon mal nicht so genau, was das eigentlich tut. Mag da vielleicht ein paar Leute geben, die haben da eben Einblick in der Firma, aber eben nur die. Also eine öffentliche Verifikation der Funktionsweise, wie man das auch bei so einem mechanischen System hat, wo man einfach reingucken kann mit Rädchen und Stangen und so weiter. Das kann man ja dann irgendwie alles noch verstehen. Also sowas gibt es da schon mal nicht. Bloß Open Source löst ein anderes, ganz wichtiges zentrales Problem nicht, nämlich die Manipulierbarkeit, weil ich kann tausendmal Open Source durchlesen, wenn am Ende was anderes drauf läuft auf der Maschine, dann hilft mir der ganze Open Source nichts. Der Punkt ist ja, in dem Moment, wo das Gerät da steht und einfach für mich vollkommen verschlossen, einfach nur so als schwarzer Kasten, irgendwelche Tätigkeiten durchführt, kann ich einfach nicht sicher sagen, genau der Code, den ich mir vorher mit meinen 20 Hackerfreunden drei Wochen lang angeschaut habe, ist derjenige, der da jetzt ist. Und außerdem kann ich auch nicht sagen, dass ein Feder frei läuft.
Also wenn ihr jetzt noch nicht wisst, welche CD ihr diese Woche unbedingt gewinnen wollt und immer noch keine Ahnung habt, was ihr Silvester macht, dann hätten wir hier was für euch. Fritz präsentiert Die Ärzte. Wird ihr bestem Best-of-Album der Welt. Einzigartig verpackt in der weltbesten Blechbox der Welt. Und weil's live noch besser ist, spielen die Ärzte ein Open Air. Silvester. In der besten Stadt der...
Nee, in Köln.
Auch gut. Fritz bringt euch zum Silvester-Konzert der Ärzte nach Köln und versorgt euch dazu mit der weltbesten Best-of-CD der Ärzte. In der weltbesten Blechbox der Welt. Die Ärzte in Blech. CD und Konzert. Beides gewinnen. Diese Woche bei den Radio Fritzen am Morgen. Punkt 8.40 Uhr. So ungefähr jedenfalls.
Und das hört man um 2.30.12 Uhr. Mit Mario Bartsch.
Die erneuten Gespräche zur Lösung des Atomkonflikts mit dem Iran sind nach gut fünf Stunden beendet worden. Über Ergebnisse ist bisher nichts bekannt. Aus Teilnehmerkreisen verlautet er aber, dass die Verhandlungen zwischen dem EU-Außenbeauftragten Solana und Irans Chefunterhändler Larijani morgen fortgesetzt werden sollen. In Berlin hat die erste deutsche Islamkonferenz ihre Arbeit aufgenommen. Nach den dreistündigen Auftaktreffen zogen Bundesinnenminister Schäuble und die Vertreter der muslimischen Organisationen eine positive Bilanz. Mit der Konferenz will die Bundesregierung die gesellschaftliche Integration der Muslime in Deutschland verbessern und so auch den wachsenden Einfluss islamistischer Kräfte eindämmen. Bundesgesundheitsministerin Schmidt hat die geplante Gesundheitsreform gegen scharfe Angriffe der Opposition verteidigt. Das Projekt habe zum Ziel, das Geld im Gesundheitswesen genauer und sparsamer einzusetzen und die Versorgung der Patienten zu verbessern, sagte die SPD-Politikerin in einer Aktuellen Stunde im Bundestag. Das Versicherungssystem solle für alle bezahlbar bleiben. FDP, Linksfraktion und Grüne warfen der Großen Koalition dagegen ein Scheitern auf ganzer Linie vor. In Polen hat sich die innenpolitische Krise weiter zugespitzt. Bauernführer Lepper stellte bei Staatspräsident Lech Kaczynski den Antrag Ministerpräsident Jaroslaw Kaczynski und dessen Kabinett zu entlassen. Vor dem Parlamentsgebäude versammelten sich am Abend rund 200 Demonstranten und forderten den Rücktritt der Regierung. Zum Sport in der UEFA Champions League gab es am Abend zwei Vorrundenhinspiele des zweiten Spieltages mit deutscher Beteiligung. Das Spiel Werder Bremen gegen den FC Barcelona ging 1 zu 1 aus. In der Partie Intermai-Land gegen den FC Bayern München gewannen die Bayern mit 2 zu 0. Heute Nacht letzte Schauer an der Neiße, ansonsten ziehen ein paar Wolkenfelder durch. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 13 bis 8 Grad. Am Tag ist es erst neblig trüb, später lockert es auf, bei Höchstwerten um 22 Grad. A24-Britzwalk Richtung Berliner Ring zwischen Neuruppin und Reihe Kaffeland ist ein Schwertransport unterwegs, der nicht überholt werden kann. A111-Stadtautobahn Oranienburg Richtung Charlottenburg. Zwischen Saatwinkler Damm und Dreieck Charlottenburg ist der rechte Fahrstreifen wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Und A111-Stadtautobahn Charlottenburg Richtung Oranienburg im Tunnel Ortskern Tegel ist der linke Fahrstreifen wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. In der Gegenrichtung ist der rechte Fahrstreifen ebenfalls wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, fünf Minuten nach halb eins. Zwölf, halb zwölf.
Und Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Prignitz.
Ja.
Was war das denn?
Kaufst du mir auch einen Computer? Das ist Der Plan gewesen. Eine ziemlich kultige Band aus den 80er Jahren, die so ein bisschen auch als Wegbereiter der neuen deutschen Welle gilt. Unter Der Plan in der Wikipedia findet sich da so einiges und das war halt Gummitwist. Und da bin ich auch erst, muss ich sagen, vor kurzem drauf gestoßen, als ich dieses schöne Interview gemacht habe mit Peter Glaser zum 25 Jahre Chaos Computer Club. Das haben wir auch noch nicht erwähnt. Wir sind 25 Jahre alt geworden, am 12. September. Und Chaos Radio Express gibt es ein wenig dieses Interview.
Ich hatte ja auch vier Tage vorher erst geboten. Ja, schon gut.
Achso, herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Peter erzählt auf jeden Fall, dass der Sänger dieser Band sozusagen ihm das erste Mal vom CTC erzählt hat, von Dr. Wau und so kam das. Na ja, und dann dachte ich mir, das ist doch mal genau das Richtige hier für unsere kleine Sendung, oder?
Unsere kleine Sendung ist das Chaos Radio.
Genau.
Das gibt es immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Heute geht es um Wahlcomputer. Und wann haben wir den Holland gewählt? Zwei Monaten, oder? Acht Wochen? Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Das kann uns Rob ganz gut sagen. Und den haben wir jetzt auch am Apparat.
Hallo Rob.
Ihr wählt demnächst.
Wir wählen demnächst, und zwar am 22.
November. Und das macht ihr mit Wahlcomputern?
Das machen wir mit Wahlcomputern und zwar flächendeckend. Es gibt noch, ich glaube, zehn ganz kleine Gemeinden, so Dörfer, wo es noch mit Papier gewählt wird und alles andere ist Computern.
Zwei Fragen. Ist das mit den Wahlcomputern gut oder böse? Die andere Frage, warum machen diese zehn kleinen Dörfer nicht mit?
Es ist böse und die machen nicht mit. Meistens ärgern die sich total, aber sind Leute in der Gemeinderat, die nicht wollen. Aber die Beamten ärgern sich alle total, weil die wollen alle ganz gerne Computer haben.
Warum? Also wie begründen die das?
Die begründen das, weil es einfacher ist und weil sie sich moderner fühlen. Das sind so die Begründungen. Und wir haben hier vielleicht mal ein bisschen erzählen, wie das hier aussieht. Es gibt ja eigentlich zwei Lieferanten. Es gibt NEDAP, die gibt es in Deutschland auch. Da habt ihr bestimmt schon drüber geredet. NEDAP baut also diese ziemlich alte Wahlmaschinen so aus den 80ern raus. Und dann gibt es noch SDU und SDU, das ist die Staatsdrückerei. Das ist die alte, so wie in Deutschland die Bundesdrückerei. Die sind ja ebenso verselbstständigt. Heute sind noch 100 Prozent der Anteil in der Stadt. Aber das wird gerade, glaube ich, verkauft. Die Bietung läuft jetzt. Und zwei der potentiellen vier Käufer sind Hedge Funds. Und das ist also die andere Anbieter von Wahltechnik. Und die haben etwas, das nennt sich New Vote. Das hört sich auch schon richtig schön an, was?
Neu Sprech, Neue Vote.
New Speak, New Vote, genau. Und New Vote sind Embedded Computern, wo Windows drauf läuft und mit einem Touchscreen. Da ist auch ein ganz, ganz bequemes GPRS-Modem drin. Und das New Vote-Programm heißt nicht, man besitzt die Computer als Gemeinde, sondern die kommen vorbei. Man mietet also als Dienstleistung die ganze Wahlen. Die sagen zu den Beamten, mach euch keine Sorgen mehr, wir machen das alles für euch. Gebt uns nur die Leute, die in den Wahlämtern sitzen müssen. Wir trainen die, also wir machen alle Training, alle Unterricht. Wir stellen die Leute hin und dann abends erzählen wir euch, wer gewonnen hat. So sieht Wahl als komplett Dienstleistung, also komplett outsourced. So sieht das aus. Das ist New Vote. Das hat aber ein kleines Marktanteil, das ist im Moment noch so 6, 7 Prozent. Die haben nur einen Großstadt und das ist leider Amsterdam, wo ich wohne. Und eigentlich der Rest von Holland, die restlichen 90, 92 Prozent sind NEDAP.
Und NEDAP ist ja sozusagen auch dann der Generallieferant für den europäischen Raum sozusagen.
Ja, das ist der einzige, der es im Moment geschafft hat. So anderen Länder, die haben in Frankreich gibt es welche, in Deutschland gibt es welche, in Irland haben die Flächen gekauft und nicht eingesetzt. Aber das sind so die großen Länder, wo NEDAP verkauft hat.
Ihr habt ja jetzt eine Kampagne gestartet. Wir vertrauen Wahlcomputer nicht. Auf holländisch kann ich das nicht aussprechen. Wie heißt das?
Wahlvertrauen ist der im Computer schmied.
Genau.
Muss man auch nicht aussprechen.
Aber genau unter diesem Satz gibt es dann auch die passenden Domänen. Das ist eure Webseite. Und was ist da bisher passiert? Was habt ihr da gemacht?
Was haben wir gemacht? Eigentlich, Anfang war so die letzte Lokalwahl hier. Die waren im März 2006, also dieses Jahr. Und da haben Barry Wells, ein Freund von mir und ich, haben da gewählt, hier in Amsterdam, auf diesen New-Vote-Computern. Und als wir unseren Singer auf diesen Bildschirm gelegt haben, haben wir gedacht, das passiert uns nur genau einmal. Dann haben wir eigentlich angefangen zu recherchieren. Wir wussten schon eine Menge, weil es gab schon diese Situation in Irland. Da waren wir uns bewusst. Und es gibt natürlich die ganze Situation mit Die Bold in America. Also wir waren uns schon von der Menge bewusst. Aber dann haben wir angefangen, echt mal für Jetzt ist Ernst zu recherchieren. Daraus haben wir ein Website gemacht. Das war dann eigentlich Mai, Juni so. Und dann kam hier ein dokumentierter Fall von Fraud, also von Wahlbetrug, während den Lokalwahlen. Und das war mit einer Nädabkiste. Das war eine ziemlich komische Situation. Das war nicht wirklich eine technische Angriff gegen eine Nädab, sondern ein Typ saß dahinter und hat angeblich zu den alten Leute, die da waren, gekommen sind, weil das war ein Altersheim, hat er gesagt, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, Sie haben jetzt schon gewählt, obwohl die noch nicht bestätigten, auf die Wahltaste gedrückt hatten. Und dann hat er schnell sich selbst und Wahltaste gedrückt. Und zwar 180 Mal, obwohl er an den Rest des Dorfes nur zehnmal gewählt wurde. Das ist dann natürlich aufgefallen. Und da wird jetzt ermittelt und Staatsanwaltschaft. Da ist viel los und er hat auch ziemlich skurrile Sachen gemacht. Er hat die anderen Mitglieder des Wahlamtes mit den Rücken zu ihm platziert, weil das war bequemer, weil dann konnten die mit dem Wahlalarm die Papierkertchen tun und dann konnte er das mit dem schwierigen Wahlcomputer tun. Also alles ziemlich komisch. Aber das hat dann die Medien ergriffen. Und das haben wir eigentlich als Grund gesehen, dass unsere Webseite dann schon fast fertig war zu launchen.
Wie reagieren die Medien denn insgesamt in Holland? Sind die dem eher wohlgesonnen oder stehen die dem auch negativ gegenüber?
Also die Medien hier sind total toll. Also das Thema ist hier, sagen wir mal, 20 Jahre vernachlässigt. Und genau die letzten vier, fünf Jahre fängt das alles an, international ein bisschen anders gesehen zu werden. Und die haben das total ignoriert. Die haben das weggemacht. Ja, das gibt es hier aber nicht. Und unsere Wahlcomputer sind komplett 100 Prozent sicher. Hacker haben keine Chance.
Ist ja auch illegal in den Niederlanden.
Ja, genau, also die haben das komplett weg ignoriert und komplett weg. Und ja, jetzt, wenn man unsere Webseite durchliest, dann sieht man, wir haben da einen Punkt. Es gibt keine richtige Inspection. Es gibt dieses TNO, ein bisschen so wie in Deutschland die PTB. Die testen eigentlich nur einen Wahlcomputer. Und das steht im Regeln, was ein Wahlcomputer haben muss, steht nichts über Security. Da wird also auch nichts getestet. Es ist vielleicht als interessanter Punkt, es ist in Holland komplett legal, ein Wahlcomputer zu bauen. Der besteht aus einem Windows 95 PC ohne Patches, mit einem Always-on-ADSL- oder sogar wireless Internetverbindung, mit einem eingebauten Internet-Information-Server von Microsoft Version 1.0, ungepatcht, und dann auf einen ASP-Script auf diesen Web-Server zu wählen, mit einem ganz frühen Internet-Explorer-Browser, auch ungepatcht. Das wäre hier komplett legal. Oh Mann.
Wie sieht es in Deutschland aus?
So lange? Es wäre nur legal, Entschuldigung, ich bin dazu zu negativ. Es wäre nur legal, wenn die Knöpfe auf dem Bildschirm bestimmte Größen haben und dass alles auch ein klein bisschen Wasser auf dem Tastatur- oder Bildschirm abkann, ohne dass man da ein Elektro-Klick bekommt.
Sie haben schon an alles gedacht.
Wir haben schon an alles gedacht, genau.
Habt ihr keine anderen Gesetze, die man da zur Anwendung bringen könnte, damit das nicht stattfindet?
Na ja, ist schwierig. Wir haben hier sowieso die Situation, wir haben eine Verfassung, aber wir dürfen Gesetze nicht gegen diese Verfassung prüfen. Das hört sich komisch an, aber so ist es.
Das hab ich noch nicht mal verstanden.
Es gibt kein Bundesverfassungsgericht?
Es gibt kein Bundesverfassungsgericht. Also es gibt eine Verfassung, aber kein Verfassungsgericht.
Wer wacht über die Verfassung?
Naja, eher quasi unsere Politiker selber.
Praktisch, wa?
Ich finde es vergriffen, dass das all die Jahre gut gegangen ist.
So gut ist es ja gar nicht.
Aber gut genug, also ich meine, es hätte schlimmer kommen können.
Voting is not allowed in the Netherlands.
Ja, Voting ist schon erlaubt. So schlimm ist es nicht. Es steht da nur eine Firma und die erzählen dann abends, die Politiker, wer gewonnen hat.
Was, ähm, ja, was siehst du denn da jetzt als die notwendigen nächsten Schritte?
Na, es wird hier eine Menge passieren. Es ist hier schon eine Menge am passieren. Also die Medien haben alle jetzt geschneit. Es gab hier einen großen Consumer-Programm. Die haben die Kampagne erwähnt. Da haben 1, 6 Millionen Leute dazu geschaut. Das ist 10 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Ähm, also alle hier in Holland wissen, da ist was los mit diesem Wahlcomputer. Und alle Medien verstehen, dass das jetzt, das Innenministerium langsam die Überblick auf diese, die Kontrolle über diese Diskussion komplett am verlieren ist. Und das wird nur noch schlimmer. Also die, da, es entsteht Energie und die haben keine Kontrolle mehr.
Wird das etwas ändern?
Ich schätze, es hat schon was geändert. Auf jeden Fall verstehen jetzt alle, dass da eine internationale Diskussion läuft und dass wir in Holland eher die Ausnahme sind als die Regel. Und es fühlen sich eine ganze Menge Leute nicht mehr so ganz bequem und nicht mehr so ganz modern, als sie sich vorher gefühlt haben. Und die Story, es gibt hier keine Probleme oder alles ist sicher. Leute sehen, dass da nichts dahinter steckt. Jeder, der unser Website liest, versteht, da steckt nichts dahinter. Da ist mehr. Da ist keine Sicherheit. Da sind keine Regeln, die Sicherheit bestimmen sollten. Es wird keine Wahlcomputer getestet. Es wird eine Wahlcomputer getestet.
Das ist übrigens in Deutschland genauso. Da hat auch nur ein Wahlcomputer getestet und der Hersteller garantiert dann, dass die anderen Geräte baugleich sind.
Aber wir haben hier in Holland jetzt das Bewusstsein in den Medien und bei den Leuten entsteht langsam, dass das ein Problem ist. Und die Regierung hat schon Maßnahmen angekündigt. Die werden anfangen mit Parallel-Testing, also Wahlcomputern aus dem Normalbetrieb nehmen und da Tests drauf laufen lassen, als könnte man einen Blackbox komplett testen und alle Funktionen sehen, was sie tun, als gäbe es keine Möglichkeiten, Software mit Magic-Buttons zu bauen, als wäre es. Naja, die machen Blackbox-Testing, die machen Versiegelung, das gab es hier noch gar nicht. Es gab keine Siegel auf irgendwelche Wahlcomputern, das werden die auch machen.
Aber zurücknehmen werden die die Idee nicht? Also, dass ihr einfach mit Zetteln wählt?
Da hoffen wir drauf. Da wird noch eine Menge passieren zwischen jetzt und Wahl. Und das hängt nur davon ab, ob wir da Gemeinden hinter uns bekommen, die sagen, weil im Endeffekt entscheiden die Gemeinden. Und da gibt es eigentlich die Gemeinderat, die letztendlich entscheidet und es gibt die Beamten. Und die Beamten wollen alle Wahlcomputern, weil dann können die zwei Stunden früher nach Hause. So ist es, ich meine darum geht es. Es geht darum, dass eine Klasse von Beamten zwei Stunden früher nach Hause kann.
Es sind tatsächlich zwei Stunden, über die wir reden.
Das ist keine Problemik jetzt.
Nein, es dauert nicht die ganze Nacht. Es war immer schon so lange. Es handelt sich um zwei Stunden früher nach Hause.
Das kann die Demokratie doch mal wert sein oder nicht?
Na ja, von mir aus ja, von den Beamten aus nein. Also die wollen alle Wahlcomputern, weil dann gibt es auch nicht diesen Zweifel. Man muss nichts mehr nachzählen, es stimmt immer. Es stimmt mit sich selbst. Wir sehen das nicht, aber zumindest stimmt es immer mit sich selbst. Wenn man ein Zettelchen zählt, dann muss das alles auch noch miteinander stimmen. Wenn ich alle Stapel zusammenzähle, dann soll da wieder das Gesamtzahl rauskommen, wie viele Leute da waren. Und wenn diese Gesamtzahl am Ende der Abend nicht rauskommt, muss man alle Stapelchen noch mal zählen und das macht keinen Spaß.
Es gibt auch keine Paper Trails bei den Geräten in Holland?
Nein, gar nicht.
Ist das auch in der Diskussion? Das Grundproblem ist ja natürlich, wenn man so eine Blackbox hat und man drückt da auf eine Tasse, dann ist das irgendwo in unserem Speicher abgespeichert und man sieht nichts. Eine der Ideen sozusagen von Leuten, die zwar kritisch gegenüber Wahlcomputern sind, aber nicht so kritisch, dass sie das grundsätzlich ablehnen, ist so, na ja, wenn man jetzt zumindest was ausdrucken würde, quasi so als Beleg, nicht als Beleg, den man mit nach Hause nehmen kann, weil das öffnet ja dann wieder andere Problematiken, wie Erpressungen und so weiter, gekaufte Stimmen und so weiter, dass man dann beweisen kann, dass man auch irgendwas gewählt hat und dafür dann Geld bekommt. Das darf natürlich nicht sein, aber wenn zumindest die Stimme selber, quasi in dem Moment, wo ich sie abgebe, dann auch auf Papier gedruckt wird, was weiß ich, dann wird so ein Kärtchen abgeschnitten und das fällt dann irgendwie in so eine Kiste, also in eine Urne sozusagen, dann wäre das ja zumindest schon mal eine Möglichkeit nachzuzählen.
Naja, der Punkt ist, man muss dann entscheiden, was passiert, wenn man nachtritt und es stimmt nicht. Und in Belgien gab es dann so viele Probleme mit diesem Paper Trail, dass man da entschieden hat, wenn es nicht stimmt, dann entscheidet die Computer. Und dann bringt natürlich dieses Paper Trail nichts. Weil da gab es dann viele Probleme, es gab Leute, die das Papierchen dann nach Hause mitgenommen haben und da gab es auch noch automatische Maschinen, die sie selber hinter Glas abgeschnitten haben. Das hat dann auch wieder nicht funktioniert, weil die Papier drin festgelaufen ist und so. Also haben die entschieden, die Computer entscheidet und dann bringt nichts. Und wenn man entscheidet, dass das Papier entscheidet, dann muss man sich gerade in so einem einfachen Wahlsystem wie Holland, muss man sich fragen, was das denn bringt, das ist dieser Kram mit den Computern. Weil, überleg mal, wir machen hier pro Wahl genau eine Stimme. Wir haben keine Zweitstimme, wir haben kaum Referender. Hier in den Großstädten gibt es manchmal zwei Wahlen. Bei den Lokalwahlen ist es jedes Mal zwei, weil ich wähle dann sowohl für Bezirk als für den ganzen Stadt. Aber eigentlich für alle anderen Wahlen ist es grundsätzlich eine Wahl pro Wahlgang.
Habt ihr irgendwelche Unterstützung auch innerhalb der Regierung? Gibt es Regierungsmitglieder oder zumindest Parlamentsmitglieder, die sagen, das ist kein Schlüsselpazier?
Ja, es gibt eine Partei, die jetzt schon ziemlich groß ist, noch viel größer wird bei diesen nächsten Wahlen. Das ist die SP, die Sozialisten. Die haben das ganze thematisiert. Dann gibt es noch separaten Politiker. Es gibt ein paar Christendemokraten, die auch in 2004, als wir noch nicht da waren, schon ziemlich kritische Fragen über diese ganze Irlandgeschichte im Parlament gebracht haben. Also es gibt so hier und da bei aller Partei ein paar Leute, die es interessiert und die auch mal nachgefragt haben. Aber das Thema hier in Holland ist im letzten drei Monaten größer gewesen und hat mehr Medien bekommen als in den 20 Jahren vorher.
Ja, das ist gut. Es gibt ja auch in Irland eine ähnliche Initiative.
Ja, die Irish Citizens for Trustworthy E-Voting, EGT.
Steht ihr mit denen irgendwie in Verbindung? Ja, die sind cool. Welcherlei Aktivismus haben die da jetzt noch entfaltet? Also weißt du auch, was die Situation in Irland gerade ist?
Die Situation in Irland ist, alles ist on hold. Und wenn jetzt die linke Regierung reinkommt, dann ist das Thema sowieso erledigt, dann sind die Maschinen Schrott. Wenn die rechte Regierung reinkommt, dann werden die noch jahrelang im Lager stehen und irgendwann dann silently verschrottet werden, wenn die Welt nicht mehr so zuguckt.
Warum gibt es diesen Unterschied zwischen den beiden Lagern?
Gibt es da irgendeine Theorie?
Warum werden die Linken, die sofort verschrotten, die Rechten nicht?
Weil die Rechten nie gekauft haben. Das war ziemlich komisch, weil da gab es riesen Oppositionen. Da gab es auch ein Parlamentarverbot, die Dinger zu kaufen. Dann würde das wieder rufen. Und direkt, dass das wieder rufen würde, war das Kontrakt unterschrieben. Und dann waren die Maschinen gekauft. Und dann kamen die Untersuchungen rein und haben entschieden worden, die zu lagern und nicht zu benutzen.
Welches Lager, also welches Lager links oder rechts, war in Holland hauptsächlich dafür verantwortlich, dass das angeschafft wurde?
Links oder rechts?
Gute Frage. Das ist alles schon so lange her. Ich würde sagen, das war nicht mal eine politische Entscheidung. Da war nicht wirklich eine... Um die Geschichte zu verstehen, muss man zurück in den frühen 80ern. Und es gab damals Software für PC, für die Leute, die die Wahl organisierten. Ziemlich gute Workflow-Software, die eigentlich alles gemacht hat, was mit Wahlen zu tun hatte. Und die war von einem kleinen Softwarebüro, was gemacht werden würde von Jan Chrunendau. Jan Chrunendau ist ein wichtiger Name. Der macht das jetzt noch immer. Und der macht jetzt die Wahlmaschinen zusammen mit NEDAP. Die Firma heißt eigentlich NEDAP Chrunendau. Das ist eine Zusammenarbeit von einer großen Firma NEDAP, die die Kisten dauern, mit kleinen Firmen Chrunendau, die eigentlich alle Software macht. Die hat einfach in den 80er Jahren, nachdem er seine Software gut verkauft hat, an alle diese Gemeinden gedacht, die Software muss doch eigentlich mit Wahlmaschinen reden. Und dann hat es schon Tests gegeben. Es gab hier schon richtig, richtig früher auch mechanischen Wahlmaschinen, mal ein, zwei, nicht großflächendeckend oder so. Und dann haben die Wahlmaschinen gebaut, angefangen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass da richtig politisch entscheidender Hinterstand, anders als oh, sind wir modern. Also ich glaube nicht, dass da eine politische Entscheidung oder dass das von irgendeiner politischen Seite durchgedrückt würde.
Das heißt, das Thema wird jetzt eigentlich das erste Mal wirklich politisiert und hinterfragt. Ja, Rob, was du sonst noch fast, was du mit uns auf den Weg geben möchtest?
Ja, dass es wichtig ist, dass dieses Thema auch in Deutschland größer und größer und größer wird. Weil ihr habt da noch eine Chance einzugreifen, bevor das flächendeckend überall ist.
Wir arbeiten dran.
Ihr habt da glaube ich fast 2000 solche Netabkisten. Bin ich mit nicht irre. Wir haben hier 7, 5, 8000, das ist also fast das ganze Land. Und ihr müsst da wirklich eingreifen, bevor das flächendeckend ist. Weil es ist so viel einfacher vorzubeugen, dass die Dinger da kommen, als sie wieder loszuwerden, wenn sie da sind.
Wer treibt das in Deutschland eigentlich voran?
Firma Hals G Wahlsysteme.
Gibt es da irgendwie ein paar Köpfe, also ein paar Politiker, die man gezielt ansprechen könnte bzw. nennen könnte und sagen könnte, Politiker XY ist maßgeblich dafür verantwortlich, dass das vorangetrieben wird? Oder ist das bei uns auch so ein Ding, was sich irgendwie verselbstständigt, also was aus sich selbst heraus anfängt zu funktionieren und sich zu verbreiten?
Also ich glaube, das ist eher eine Sache, die passiert aus sich selbst heraus. Und die Begeisterung ist eigentlich auch bei allen Parteien da. Vorreiter war ja Köln, damals SPD regiert, in einem SPD-regierten Bundesland. Die erste Bauertzulassung vom Hause Schili, also auch SPD. Jetzt steigt im großen Stil in das Thema ein, Hessen, CDU regiert.
Das heißt, man kann auch nicht mal irgendwie politische Lager gegeneinander ausspielen und sagen, ha ha ha, die Rechten oder ha ha ha, die Linken, die sind gegen die Demokratie.
Ich glaube, das ist alles viel, viel mundane, viel, viel mehr boring, als du denkst, da gibt es keine Conspiracy dahinter.
Nein, mir geht es gar nicht um die Conspiracy, mir geht es einfach darum, wen man...
Nein, da geht es nicht mal Politik dahinter. Das hier, es sind so die, die Wahl, die Beamten, die Wahlen organisieren in Großstädten und die Landeswahlleiter, die das alles so schön bequem finden und die früher nach Hause dürfen.
Das wäre nur eben politisch einfacher zu diskutieren, wenn es jetzt beispielsweise ein Kind der CDU wäre oder ein Kind der SPD wäre, weil dann könnte man das jeweils andere Lager in die Spur schicken und aufwiegeln gleichsam.
Nein, leider nicht. Es ist wirklich, es handelt sich wirklich um Beamten, die das bequem finden. Da kommt der Druck her.
Ja, wenn es um die Sicherung unserer Demokratie geht, dann haben wir auch gesehen, dass sich links und rechts da beide nicht groß was nehmen.
Aber wenigstens in der Diskussion vorher.
Ja, ich würde sagen solange sie in der Opposition sind vielleicht. Aber derzeit haben wir weder das eine noch das andere. Dann sitzen alle irgendwie auf der Regierungsbank. Und ich glaube auch, dass es so ist, wie Rob sagt, dass es im Wesentlichen, und auch Ulrich hat es ja gesagt, es wird einfach noch nicht darüber nachgedacht. Es ist einfach, wir hatten auch neulich ein Gespräch mit einer Bundestagsabgeordneten, wo wir mal dieses und jenes hinterfragt haben und dann eben auch am Schluss noch mal auf diese Wahlcomputersache eingegangen sind. Und es war einfach nur ein einziges Ich-weiß-von-garnichts. Ja, das war ihr überhaupt nicht bewusst, dass es sowas gibt oder dass das irgendwie ein Problem sein könnte oder so. Dass das aber im Prinzip genau an die Wurzeln des demokratischen Systems geht, was ihren Job sozusagen überhaupt legitimiert. Das war überhaupt nicht da.
Entschuldigung, ich finde das unvorstellbar, weil das ist doch allein der Begriff des Wahlcomputers. Das muss doch jeden Demokraten irgendwie aufhorchen lassen.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Umweltpolitik am Anfang der 80er Jahre. Das muss jetzt überhaupt erst mal ins Bewusstsein stoßen, dass wir hier gerade dabei sind, die Kernfunktion unseres demokratischen Systems an Maschinen abzugeben, die einfach außerhalb jeder Kontrolle sind. Ohne, dass wir da irgendwas von haben. Wir eröffnen nur die Möglichkeit von Wahlbetrug und von Einflussnahme von irgendjemanden. Das muss ja gar nicht mal jetzt die große politische Verschwörung von rechts oder von links sein, oder gefährliche Hackerbanden mit Maske. Das ist gar nicht der Punkt. Also der Erste, der sozusagen einen Weg findet, dort in irgendeiner Form technisch was zu bewegen, der wird es dann einfach zu Geld machen. Punkt. Und dann haben wir halt einfach.
Zwei Bundestagsmandate, man hat ausgesorgt fürs Leben.
Ja, das ist schon eine ganz gute Einnahmequelle.
Rob, vielen Dank fürs Gespräch.
Ganz gerne.
Und viel Erfolg.
Jo, ihr auch.
Gute Nacht, ciao. Am letzten Mittwoch im Monat das Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club, unser Thema heute. So wie an der Musik lief, sind wir uns darüber klar geworden bzw. haben wir uns nochmal versichert, dass es hier nicht um technische Details bei Wahlmaschinen geht, bladiblub, sondern tatsächlich um Demokratie und damit um eine Metaebene, die mit den Wahlcomputern an sich und deren Funktionsweise so viel nicht mehr zu tun hat, Ulrich.
Ja, ich denke, was wir nicht so ausdrücklich herausgearbeitet haben bisher ist, dass das Öffentlichkeitsprinzip der Wahl, das heißt, dass ich zugucken kann, welchen Weg die Stimme nimmt in die Urne und wie hinterher ausgezählt wird, dass das wirklich ein demokratisches Grundprinzip ist.
Wo steht das? Steht das im Gesetz, wo das drin steht?
Das steht implizit im Grundgesetz, nämlich im Demokratieprinzip, das ist in Artikel 20 niedergelegt. Dafür gilt das sogenannte Ewigkeitsprinzip, das heißt, das kann man auch nicht durch eine Grundgesetzänderung abschaffen. Aus diesem Demokratieprinzip leitet man dieses Öffentlichkeitsprinzip ab und das ist im Bundeswahlgesetz zum Beispiel an an viele Stellen explizit aufgeführt. Dann gibt es eine Stockheimer Erklärung der OSCD-Mitgliedsstaaten, wo auch die Transparenz von Wahlen ganz detailliert festgeschrieben ist und auch die Überprüfbarkeit von Wahlen. Die Überprüfbarkeit von einer Wahl ergibt sich auch aus Artikel 41 Grundgesetz, wo festgelegt ist, dass eben eine Wahlprüfung stattfinden kann. Ich kann die Wahlen nur prüfen, wenn ich was habe, was ich prüfen kann. Das heißt, hier geht es wirklich um ganz fundamentale demokratische Grundprinzipien und nicht um irgendeinen technischen Klickerkram.
Ja, es gibt ja auch noch ein paar andere Fälle, wo man... Also ich denke, was vielen Leuten... Also zwei Sachen haben wir glaube ich auch noch nicht rausgearbeitet. Das eine ist, gleich nochmal Andreas nochmal fragen, wie eigentlich wirklich diese Geräte jetzt ganz genau sind, aber wo wir jetzt bei der Meta-Ebene sind, ist ja auch immer so die Frage, sind denn diese Betrugs-Szenarien, die wir jetzt hier so an die Wand stellen, eigentlich auch wirklich realistisch? Und ich habe vor ein paar Wochen schon auf Chaos TV so einen Video-Mitschnitt gepostet, ein Interview, also eine Aussage vor dem US House of Representatives von einem Menschen namens Clinton Curtis, der ist Programmierer in Florida, der dann halt berichtet, dass er eben von einem republikanischen Politiker dazu aufgefordert wurde, also er ist Programmierer und er sollte dann sozusagen an diesen Wahlsystemen, die dort zum Einsatz kommen, sollte eben Software entwickeln, um diesen Betrug sozusagen Ich würde sagen, unaufhintbar zu machen. Das ist ja auch so eine Dimension, die jetzt hier noch mit reinkommt. In dem Moment, wo wir eben alles maschinisiert haben, insbesondere eben durch Computer, kann einfach die Einflussnahme so subtil erfolgen, dass man sie eben nicht bemerkt. Wenn du jetzt sagst, naja, die Wahl muss nachvollziehbar sein und so weiter, man muss im Zweifelsfall die Möglichkeit haben, sie zu überprüfen. Normalerweise wird halt einmal gezählt und wenn sich alle einig sind, ist fertig. Und dann wird ja eine Überprüfung wirklich ja nur dann eingeleitet, wenn wirklich ein echter Zweifel besteht. Dann gibt es so diese Exit-Polls, die Leute werden befragt und natürlich auch die Erwartungen der Institute, die liegen nicht immer richtig. Vielleicht liegen sie aber auch immer immer richtig, wer weiß es schon so genau. Auf jeden Fall, wenn es da Abweichungen gibt, dann macht man das. Bloß diese Abweichungen, die kann man natürlich vorher schon mathematisch auch berechnen und Computer sind ein wunderbares Werkzeug, um eben sozusagen diese Abweichungen so unauffällig zu machen, dass dieser Zweifel nie aufkommt. Und von daher ist es eben noch mal eine besondere Pitfall. Ja, diese Wahlmaschinen. Du hast ja schon mal einen gesehen, Andreas.
Ja, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also da stellen wir uns mal ganz dumm. Das ist im Prinzip ein großer Koffer. Den kann man aufklappen und dann sind da links und rechts Wände. Man hat da also so eine Art Behelfswahlkabine und einen Pult mit ganz vielen Knöpfen dran und ein kleines Display. Dann wird man aufgefordert, doch einen Knopf zu drücken und seine Stimme abzugeben. Man muss dann durch Drücken auf den Stimmknopf seine Stimme bestätigen und dann hat man seine Wahl abgegeben. Und am Ende des Tages kommt aus der Maschine dann halt so ein wie so ein Kassenbong raus, ein kleiner Thermotransferdruckerausdruck, auf dem dann drauf steht, wer gewonnen hat. Also das heilige Printout, das der magische Gegenstand, der dann sagt, wer gewonnen hat. Bemerkenswert finde ich ja, wenn man so eine Ohnenwahl vergleicht, eine Wahlmaschinenwahl, dann ist ja die Handlung, die da vollführt werden, sind ja sehr sehr ähnlich. Nur dass es bei einer Ohnenwahl sich um sinnvolle Aktionen handelt und eigentlich bei der anderen Wahl um Sinn entdeht, Rituale, die einen Zweck nicht mehr erfüllen, weil die Überprüfbarkeit nicht mehr gegeben ist. Also es machen alle noch immer genau dasselbe, so ungefähr, aber dann zum Schluss kommt ein Zettel, der halt sagt, wer gewonnen hat, anstatt dass die Leute, die es durchführen, sagen, wer gewonnen hat. Im Übrigen ist es mit den Wahlen und der Wahlfälschung ja ein sehr altes Problem. Also die Päpste haben das schon seit tausend Jahren, dass dann mal ein bisschen hier betrogen und ein bisschen da bestochen wurde. Und die haben sich auch sehr abgefahrene Wahlverfahren ausgedacht. Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass dann vorne der Bischof steht und die Zettel einzeln aus der Ohne nimmt und zwei weitere sie verlesen. Und dann wird die verlesene Stimme mit Nadel und Faden auf einen langen, auf einen Faden aufgefädelt, damit man sieht, ja, diese Stimme ist entwertet. Und es passiert, Wahlbetrug passiert. Wir haben es jetzt gerade gehört aus Nierland, ein aktuelles Beispiel. Es gibt ein Beispiel eines Provinzpolitikers aus München, der versucht hat, eine Wahl zu manipulieren. Denn hier in Brandenburg und im Osten Berlins war es 1989 auch nicht ganz unüblich, das Wahlergebnis ein bisschen zu beschönigen. Und das ist auch sehr interessant, weil das wurde tatsächlich bemerkt. Also es gab Mitglieder der Bürgerbewegung in der DDR, die in die Wahllokale gegangen sind, die sich das angeguckt haben und die tatsächlich festgestellt haben, dass und wie bei diesen Wahlen manipuliert wurde.
Wie haben die das festgestellt?
Na, die haben einfach gesehen, dass da die Stimmen irgendwie komisch behandelt wurden. Dann ist da halt mal jemand mit der Ohne nach nebenan gegangen oder solche Sachen. Oder sie haben halt gezählt und dann irgendwie, hier hat aber einer nicht für die SED gewählt, das zählen wir jetzt mal nicht, das ist ungültig. Also solche Sachen passieren dann.
Die DDR hat also zugelassen, dass tatsächlich Leute, die an der Manipulation nicht beteiligt sind, dabei zugucken können, dass manipuliert wird. Sind die doof?
Naja, sie hätten es ihnen auch nicht erlauben können, da reinzugehen, aber das wäre genauso auffällig gewesen. Also es ist quasi nicht zu verhindern, dass es bemerkt wird, dass manipuliert wird. Ein bisschen ein Problem ist natürlich, wenn das zwar bemerkt wird, aber es einem keiner glaubt, wie das gerade in Mexiko passiert ist, wo es also trotz großen Protesten und nicht zu einer wirklichen Auszählung gekommen ist und trotz eines Stimmabstandes, der also unterhalb der Fuzziness-Schwelle von dem, was man beobachtet hat, an Wahlmanipulationen ein Wahlsieger erklärt wurde und immer noch, also neulich glaube ich eine Million Leute beschlossen hat, dem nächsten Gegenpräsidenten auszurufen. Also das Land ist gespalten bis aufs letzte. Und die wählen auch noch mit Papier. Und da sind halt so Sachen passiert, wie Stimmen, die auf dem Müll gefunden wurden. Es gibt Videos von Parteimitgliedern, die sogar das Ballot Stuffing betreiben. Also Ballot Stuffing ist der Fachbegriff für, du hast noch einen Stapel Wahlzettel, füllst sie halt schnell aus und wirfst sie mit in die Urne rein, bevor sie ausgezählt wird. Und das ist natürlich ein darüber hinaus gehendes Problem. Also bei Papier merkt man wenigstens noch, dass beschissen wird. Manchmal kann man dann trotzdem nichts tun, weil einfach die Umstände verhindern, dass man etwas dagegen tun kann. Aber wenigstens bemerkt man es noch. Und wenn wir demnächst nicht mal mehr merken, dass wir beschissen werden bei der Wahl, dann können wir auch nichts mehr dagegen tun.
Wir haben einen Anrufer. 0331 70 97 1 1 0 ist unsere Nummer. Und der Jens ist dran.
Hallo Jens.
Ja, hi. Und zwar habe ich sozusagen einen Vorschlag oder wie man den Wunsch nach einer schnelleren Auszählung und die Wahrung sozusagen, das Wahlrecht oder die Überprüfbarkeit zusammenführen kann. Und eigentlich wäre es doch nett, wenn sozusagen die Wahlcomputer für sich die Ergebnisse zählen und gleichzeitig sozusagen, wenn man gesagt hat, ok, also auf den Knopf drückt, jetzt wähle ich, bekommt der Wählende eine Quittung in die Hand, auf die er noch mal raufgucken kann und die dann in die Ohne wirft. Sodass am Ende des Wahltages die Daten aus dem Computer gleich an die Zentrale geschickt werden können. Das Wahllokal bekommt vom Computer einen Bon, wo alles zusammengezählt ist und kann dann für sich aber nochmal die Quittung dann in einer Wahlohne nachzählen und mit dem Bon vergleichen und wenn da was nicht stimmt, dann können sie ja immer noch in der Zentrale anrufen und sagen, hallo, nee, wir haben ja ein anderes Ergebnis. Aber so haben die dann immerhin in der Zentrale schon mal ein schnelleres Ergebnis, was sich dann halt in einigen Stunden dann nochmal dann tatsächlich richtig bestätigt wird durch die OKs aus den Wahllokalen. Also könnte man vielleicht das zusammenführen, aber...
Ja, das ist der Paper Trail, davon hatten wir es vorhin schon. Also diese Idee ist natürlich auch noch mehreren gekommen, dass man das ja kombinieren könnte. So Wahl auf Papier mit einem Ausdruck.
Ja, nur eben, dass der Wählende direkt auf die Quittung in die Hand bekommt und halt genau gucken kann, ja, habe ich denn das auch wirklich gewählt, was ich wollte. Also hat der Computer das sozusagen richtig mitgekriegt. Und darum eben, dass der Wählende das nochmal in die Ohne schmeißt, dass die das dann nochmal nachziehen können.
Da gibt es auch eine sehr interessante Variante. Das ist der Hamburger Wahlstift. Das hat vielleicht noch nicht jeder gehört. Da hat man tatsächlich irgendwie ein ganz normales, also ein fast ganz normales Stück Papier und einen Stift in der Hand, einen speziellen Stift. Und auf dem Papier sind so eine Art 2D-Barcodes drauf, die man mit bloßem Auge gar nicht sieht. Und der merkt also, wo auf dem Papier man sein Kreuzchen macht. Und dann hat man am Ende des Tages Wahlzettel, die aussehen wie die Wahlzettel, die man bisher auch hat. Man hat aber schon mal ein vorläufiges Endergebnis, das aus diesem Stift rausfällt. Also ich denke, wichtig ist, wenn man so was andenkt, wenn man so was macht, dass man das nach wie vor, sozusagen das auf dem Papier vermerkte, das Verbindliche ist und das das Ergebnis, das aus der Maschine fällt, quasi bloß als vorläufiges Endergebnis benutzt wird für, was man schon mal Hochrechnungen melden kann und dann aber die Auszählung weiter stattfindet. Das Problem ist bloß, dann müssen die Beamten immer noch zwei Stunden später nach Hause. Deswegen wird das nicht passieren.
Ja, da muss man sich halt überlegen, ob auch der finanzielle Aufwand, das überhaupt wert ist, dass man jetzt bessere Ergebnisse schneller hat oder so.
Ich meine, wie schnell will man sie noch haben? Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, so in den 80er Jahren hatten wir bei uns in der Schulklasse immer einen großen Spaß, weil wir zu jedem Wahl haben immer eine Wahlparty gemacht. Das war ganz toll. Da kam man irgendwie um 18 Uhr zusammen und hat dann schon mal die erste Flasche aufgemacht. Und man war schon ziemlich besoffen, bevor dann wirklich dann so spät in der Nacht das Endergebnis eintrudelte. Und seitdem das jetzt irgendwie schneller geht, also später wurden dann diese Partys total. Genau, das war vollkommen unspannend. Da kam dann irgendwie so eine Minute danach erstmal die Prognose, die stimmte schon mal so Pim-Pimal-Daumen. Und 20 Minuten später die erste Hochrechnung. Und nach einer halben Stunde war es dann eigentlich weitgehend gegessen. Das war dann einfach nicht mehr spannend. Ich kann nicht so recht feststellen, dass es irgendwie ein Zeitproblem gibt. Und das Beklagen von ein paar Leuten, dass sie früher nach Hause wollen, mein Gott, dann sollen sie keine Wahlhelfer sein. Eine Wahl findet alle vier Jahre statt auf der jeweiligen Ebene oder fünf sogar teilweise. Und das ist nun wirklich keine Belastung, die unzumutbar ist.
Aber tatsächlich finde ich das mit dem Stift eigentlich ziemlich schick, muss ich sagen.
Auch da muss man wieder fragen, welches Problem willst du denn eigentlich lösen? Ich meine, wenn entweder gilt das, was der Computer sagt, das ist das, was wir nicht wollen, oder es gilt das, was auf dem Zettel steht, dann kannst du auch gleich auf dem Zettel drauf machen. Dann müssen wir nicht für Millionen Geld uns Systeme anschaffen, die dann am Ende nur ein Problem sind.
Weil die dann noch schnell kaputt gehen.
Ja, die kaputt gehen und was ist, wenn du dann wirklich eine Abweichung hast? Dann wird das auch alles total unübersichtlich. Also dann schon lieber ein paar ungültige Stimmen und ein paar komische Geschichten auf den Wahlzetteln, wie wir das bisher hatten. Weil es macht ja auch dann diese Transparenz. Es schränkt die Transparenz einfach ein. Also wir haben das vorhin gesehen, die ersten Wahlhelfer, die bei der rein manuellen Wahl waren, die also so komplett, ohne auch nur mit der Wimper zu zucken, meinen so ja super, habe ich alles verstanden, habe ich alles nachvollziehen können, alles super. Und dann die alternative Wahlmaschine, ja weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, da kam irgendwie was aus dem Gerät raus, keine Ahnung, ob da jemand seine Finger drin hatte. In dem Moment, wo du halt so ein System damit reinbringst, machst du es komplexer. Du magst da zwar wieder irgendeine Systematik haben, mit irgendwie der Zettel und keine Ahnung, aber am Ende würde ich sagen, du wählst wahrscheinlich sogar A und auf dem Zettel steht B und die Leute werfen es trotzdem in die Ohren.
Ja, schönen Abend euch noch.
Dir auch, tschüss. Die Nummer des Blue Moons, des Chaos Radios ist die 0331 70 97 1112. Die hat der Dirk angerufen, der will was gegen Wahlcomputer sagen. Wieso hast du jetzt auf einmal was dagegen? Wir machen die die ganze Zeit Werbung für die Dinger.
Ja, weil ich bin der Meinung, jeder der sich ein bisschen mit Computern auskennt, wird ganz genau, dass die Dinger einfach nicht sicher sein können. Und dass die Manipulation von außen her einfach mal die jedem ist.
Ist sie das, Jungs, von außen? Also kann ich das Ding von außen manipulieren? Also wenn ich davor stehe, wenn ich gerade meine Stimme abgebe, kann ich dann irgendein elektrisches Gerät ums Handgelenk haben?
Also das ist glaube ich so das Bedrohungsszenario, das von der PTB geprüft wird, dass da jemand ankommt und vor den Augen der Wahlhelfer im Wahllokal anfängt mit Wunschelrouten oder Voodoo-Gesängen. Ja, das kennen Sie von den Geldspielautomaten.
Es gab tatsächlich Geldspielautomaten, da hat man dann so ein Taser rangehalten, so ein Taschen-Elektroschocker und dann macht das... und dann kam das ganze Geld raus.
Welche waren das? Geht das noch?
Das ist lange genug her, dass es irgendwie mittlerweile nicht mehr geht.
Ach Mist.
Und also die Resistenz gegen Angriffe ist verschieden. Jetzt wurden ja in den USA gerade die Diebold-Wahlmaschinen noch mal näher angeguckt von einem Team um Professor Felten. Und die sind also soweit gekommen, da gibt es eine Klappe, die kann man aufmachen, dann kurz so ein Modul reinstecken, wieder rausziehen, dann hat das Gerät ein Virus und wenn dann irgendjemand mal mit dem Stimmmodul vorbeikommt und die Stimmen einsammelt, dann wandert der Virus auch von Wahlmaschine zu Wahlmaschine und manipuliert das Gerät auch so, dass hinterher keine Spuren mehr sichtbar sind von dem eigentlichen Manipulationsprozess.
Verhasst?
Damit wählen die da?
Und ein Richter hat gesagt, irgendwie ja, es ist jetzt nicht sicher, aber es ist leider sechs Wochen vor der Wahl, deswegen wählen wir auch diesmal wieder mit Wahlmaschine und nicht mit Zettel. Und also ja, richtig, es handelt sich um Computer und Computer sind manipulierbar. Die NEDAP-Geräte sind ein bisschen schwieriger manipulierbar, weil das einfach Technik aus der Steinzeit ist. Also nicht ein Windows PC wie die Leboit-Geräte, sondern es ist so ein 68.000. Man kann sich das vorstellen wie so ein Amiga, nur ohne Grafikchips ist das intern. Und also auch aus der Zeit und so und die Fotos in der CT sind sehr schön. Da sieht man also, dass es alles 25 Jahre alt Technik ist. Das ist nicht ganz einfach. Da muss man das Gerät aufmachen, eine andere Software reinstecken, grob gesprochen. Und naja, in Deutschland tun sie da so Siegel drauf. Diese Siegel sehen aus wie Zweckformetiketten, die aus dem Laserdrucker rausgefallen sind, sind ähnlich sicher. Also jeder, der in der Lage ist, auf dem Laserdrucker was auszudrucken kann, dieses Siegel umgehing, ganz abgesehen davon, dass man es ablösen kann. Es gibt ja da eine Stellungnahme des Innenministeriums zum Thema Manipulationssicherheit, insbesondere der Niederschlagmaschinen, und die stellen sich also auf den Standpunkt, dass es unmöglich wäre, die Software zu manipulieren, weil der Source-Code dafür nicht verfügbar wäre. Und die Lebensfremdheit, solche Einstellungen, ist wirklich unglaublich, weil jeder, der schon mal auf einem Windows ein Virus gesehen hat, weiß, dass man nicht unbedingt den Source-Code von Windows braucht, um für Windows ein Virus zu schreiben. Also die tägliche Erfahrung eines jeden Computernutzers widerspricht eigentlich der Sicherheitseinschätzung des Innenministeriums. Also insofern würde ich mich da anschließen. Computern kann man nicht trauen, weil es unglaublich viele Wege gibt, da Hintertüren einzubauen und sie dazu zu bringen, etwas anderes zu tun, als sie eigentlich tun sollen.
Ich mach mal einen kurzen Reklame-Einschub, aber du brauchst den Jingle jetzt nicht zu spielen. Wer sich für alte Computer interessiert, also Retro-Computing, wie man das so schön nennt, für den haben wir auch noch eine kleine Veranstaltung in Berlin bei unserem nächsten Datengarten am 12.
Ist das jetzt wieder die Reklame? Am 12.
Oktober 2006 haben wir den nächsten Datengarten im Chaos Computer Club Berlin und das Thema ist Retro-Computing.
Oder wie waren die Computer denn früher?
Wir wollen einmal einen Blick in die Vergangenheit werfen und uns Computer aus einer Zeit vor Multitasking und Internet ansehen. Interessierte, die noch einen alten Computer zuhause haben, sind eingeladen diesen mitzubringen.
Es gibt alles.
CPM, alte Computer, Restauration von alten Maschinen, Datenkonvertierung und tolle Hacks und lustiges Zeug obendrauf. Und wenn ihr kommen wollt, dann schaut ihr auf berlin.ccc.de und da guckt ihr unter Datengarten und da steht alles drin.
Na, falsche Taste, Entschuldigung.
So ist die Werbung zu Ende, jetzt hab ich die ganze Ponte kaputt gemacht.
Total.
Komm, mach mal noch mal, mach mal noch mal, ne?
So, fertig. Ich wollte ja nur kurz drauf hinweisen, jetzt hab ich schon wieder fast wieder auf einem anderen Thema abgelenkt. Am 12. October. Ja, also alte Scheiße ist da drin in diesem Ding. Das ist ganz gut, weil im Prinzip die alten Rechner haben den Vorteil, dass man doch deutlich mehr darüber weiß. Also in so einem Satelliten, der so durch die Gegend fliegt, da steht auch nicht irgendwie der neueste Core 2 Duo drin, sondern das ist alles abgehangene Prozessortechnik, die man so versteht und wo man irgendwie einiges darüber gelernt hat mit der Zeit.
Das ist auch scheiße, wenn man immer hoch fliegen muss zum Rebooten.
Insofern ist das sinnvoll, aber natürlich sind auch diese Maschinen, wenn ich es richtig mitbekommen habe, dieser NEDAP Hersteller, der wehrt sich sozusagen allein schon gegen die Einschätzung, dass es sich dabei um einen richtigen Computer handelt. Das sieht er halt gar nicht so. Das sind halt irgendwie Maschinen.
Was unterscheidet denn eine beliebige Maschine von einem Computer?
Ein Computer ist ein universelles Rechengerät, während eine Maschine einen speziellen, vordefinierten Zweck hat.
Das kann man natürlich simulieren auf einem Computer, aber das erinnert nichts an der Tatsache, dass es eben auf einer Struktur aufbaut, die man eben leicht manipulieren kann. Und wenn man es eben gelingt, den Source Code, oder nicht mal den Source Code, also wenn es gelingt, in irgendeiner Form Zugriff auf dieses Gerät zu bekommen. Und das ist halt einfach möglich, ja. In dem Fall der Systeme, wie sie heute eingesetzt werden, die werden da halt morgens so angeliefert. Gut, schön, super. Dann kommt die Maschine halt an, die Maschine mit dem Bingen, und die verspricht halt alles richtig zu machen. Wer hat das überprüft? Wo? Wie? Wie hat er das von überprüft?
Also wir wissen ja, wie das geprüft wird in Deutschland, und da findet einfach keine Kontrolle statt. Es gibt eine Bauartprüfung, das heißt, der Hersteller verspricht, dass das Gerät, was in Gemeinde geliefert wurde, genauso funktioniert wie das, was mal von der PTB getestet wurde.
Das ist so wie eine allgemeine Betriebserlaubnis beim MOFA.
Genau, genau.
Also wenn es keine in deiner Maschine, nur 50.
25 steht doch drin.
Also wenn es keine getunten MOFAs gibt, dann gibt es auch keine gehackten Wahlmaschinen. Da sind wir uns glaube ich einig.
Da sind wir uns einig, Dirk. Danke für deinen Anruf.
Also wenn ihr jetzt noch nicht wisst, welche CD ihr diese Woche unbedingt gewinnen wollt und immer noch keine Ahnung habt, was hier Sylvester macht, dann hätten wir hier was für euch. Fritz präsentiert Die Ärzte. Mit ihrem besten Best-of-Album der Welt. Einzigartig verpackt in der weltbesten Blechbox der Welt. Und weil's live noch besser ist, spielen die Ärzte ein Open Air. Sylvester, in der besten Stadt der...
Nee, in Köln.
Auch gut. Fritz bringt euch zum Sylvester-Konzert der Ärzte nach Köln und versorgt euch dazu mit der weltbesten Best-of-CD der Ärzte. In der weltbesten Blechbox der Welt. Die Ärzte in Blech. CD und Konzert, beides gewinnen. Diese Woche bei den Radio-Fritzen am Morgen. Punkt 8.40 Uhr. So ungefähr jedenfalls.
Und das hört man um eine nach halb eins.
Die erneuten Gespräche zur Lösung des Atomkonflikts mit dem Iran sind nach gut fünf Stunden beendet worden. Über Ergebnisse ist bisher nichts bekannt. Aus Teilnehmerkreisen verlautet aber, dass die Verhandlungen zwischen dem EU-Außenbeauftragten Solana und Irans Chefunterhändler Larijani heute fortgesetzt werden sollen. In Berlin hat die erste deutsche Islamkonferenz ihre Arbeit aufgenommen. Nach den dreistündigen Auftaktreffen zogen Bundesinnenminister Schäuble und die Vertreter der muslimischen Organisationen eine positive Bilanz. Mit der Konferenz will die Bundesregierung die gesellschaftliche Integration der Muslime in Deutschland verbessern und so auch den wachsenden Einfluss islamistischer Kräfte einblämmen. Bundesgesundheitsministerin Schmidt hat die geplante Gesundheitsreform gegen scharfe Eingriffe der Opposition verteidigt. Das Projekt habe zum Ziel, das Geld im Gesundheitswesen genauer und sparsamer einzusetzen und die Versorgung der Patienten zu verbessern, sagte die SPD-Politikerin in einer Aktuellen Stunde im Bundestag. Das Versicherungssystem solle für alle bezahlbar bleiben. FDP, Linksfraktionen und Grüne warfen der großen Koalition dagegen ein Scheitern auf ganzer Linie vor. In Polen hat sich die innenpolitische Krise weiter zugespitzt. Bauernführer Leper stellte bei Staatspräsident Lech Kaczynski den Antrag Ministerpräsident Jaroslaw Kaczynski und dessen Kabinette zu entlassen. Vor dem Parlamentsgebäude versammelten sich am Abend rund 200 Demonstranten und forderten den Rücktritt der Regierung. Zum Fußball am zweiten Spieltag der UEFA Champions League trennten sich Werder Bremen und Barcelona 1 zu 1 unentschieden. Bayern München besiegte auswärts Intermai-Land mit 2 zu 0. Heute Nacht letzte Schauer an der Neiße, ansonsten ziehen ein paar Wolkenfelder durch. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 13 bis 8 Grad. Am Tag ist es erst neblig trüb, später lockert es auf bei Höchstwerten um 22 Grad. A111 Stadt Autobahn Charlottenburg Richtung Oranienburg im Tunnel Erortskern Tegel ist der linke Fahrstreifen wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt, in der Gegenrichtung ist der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Mario, gleich vier Minuten nach halb eins.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2 dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Chaos Radio 117 mit dem Thema Wahlcomputer.
Weil er nicht so witzig ist. Er ist nur ein dummer Puppe, der auf sein Handy ordnet.
Chaosradio 117, das Thema ist Wahlcomputer. Wir waren noch nicht Meter genug, haben wir eben festgestellt.
Ja und schon haben wir wieder eine 9-Eleven-Diskussion gehört.
Wir haben nämlich noch gar nicht darüber geredet, ob es da vielleicht auch gute Gründe gibt für Wahlcomputer. Zum Beispiel, weil man mehr digitale Demokratie haben kann, mehr direkte Demokratie.
Mehr digitale Demokratie finde ich gut.
Wir hatten es ja vorhin von der PTB, die jetzt online Warten testet, sicherlich genauso gründlich und mit Sachverstand, wie sie die Wahlcomputer getestet haben. Es ist die Frage, will man das überhaupt? Also ich denke, dass die Vision natürlich eine tolle ist. Unsere Demokratie ist eine relativ indirekte. Und wenn man sich mal das griechische Originalmodell anguckt, da fand halt Demokratie noch direkt statt. Da waren die Städte so klein, dass man sich jeden Tag auf dem Marktplatz traf, dem Polis, wo ja auch das Wort Politik kommt, und sich da einfach so lange anbrüllte, bis man zu einer Lösung gekommen war und das dann einfach umgesetzt hat. Und das ist natürlich was völlig anderes, als alle vier bis fünf Jahre mal sein Kreuzchen irgendwo zu machen oder den Knopf zu drücken. Und einer der Vorschläge, den man immer wieder hört, auch von technikaffinen Leuten, ist doch, dass viel direkter zu machen. Also einfach wir stimmen jetzt einfach über alles ab. Jeden Morgen liest man irgendwie seine Zeitung, isst ein paar Frühstücksbrötchen und macht dann noch die Abstimmung des Tages. Klingt doch erstmal gut, oder?
Also ich finde, es klingt furchtbar.
Auf jeden Fall kann man ja der Meinung sein, dass man mehr abstimmen sollte, vielleicht wie in der Schweiz mit mehr Volksabstimmungen. Da kann man ja die eine oder die andere Meinung zu haben. Auf jeden Fall sind mehr Abstimmungen sicherlich einfacher, wenn man da technische Hilfsmittel hat oder wenn man über Internet abstimmen kann. Das muss man wohl schon zugeben. Aber ob man wirklich mehr Demokratie hat, wenn man nicht weiß, ob man tatsächlich wählt oder ob nur irgendwas hinten aus der Abstimmungsmaschine rauskommt, das ist natürlich die andere Frage.
Also dass das mal einfacher ist mit dem Computer, das würde ich ja mal stark bezweifeln. Also allein der Zwang, Internet aufrecht zu halten.
Ja, das war jetzt gar nicht mal so sehr technisch gemeint, sondern aus administrativer Sicht, wenn ich jemand bin, der eine Wahl veranstalten muss.
Klar, verstehe. Ja, wenn man es halt irgendwie automatisieren könnte, aber ich habe da einfach echt mal große Zweifel, wenn ich mir schon die den Zustand von Seiten, die versuchen, mir Musik zu verkaufen, anschaue. Ja, also die sind ja nicht mal in der Lage, einen normalen Bezahlprozess in irgendeiner Form durchzukriegen.
Also bei den Porno-Seiten klappt das ganz gut. Habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Ja, aber die bieten keine Musik an.
Das ist richtig. Wenn, dann ist es schlecht.
Aber man wohl wenigstens mit Orgeln gespiegelt.
Um auf das Thema Internetwahlen zurückzukommen, also ich sehe da auch mehrere Probleme. Also ganz abgesehen davon, dass, also solange das mit dem Online-Banking nicht sicher klappt, solange wir solche Phänomene wie Phishing haben und jeden Tag Zehntausende von Leuten, die ihr Geld irgendwo hin überweisen oder auf die falsche Webseite gehen und da ihre PIN eingeben, wird das auch mit den Internetwahlen sicher nichts werden. Und ein ganz anderes Problem ist sicherlich auch der Aspekt der Freiheit in Freigleich und Geheim bei unserer Wahl, weil also in der Wahlkabine kann ich einfach meine Stimme ungehindert abgeben. Da steht keiner hinter mir und hält mir die Pistole an den Kopf und sagt, wähl das oder wähl das.
Vor zwei Stunden hast du noch erzählt, dass einer hinter dir gestanden hat.
Ja, aber ohne Pistole.
Das stimmt.
Ohne Pistole und er ist von links nach rechts gelaufen und sie wurden sofort ermahnt, es doch bitte bleiben zu lassen. Also insofern wurde das halbwegs sichergestellt.
Na gut.
Aber ja.
Aber vielleicht gibt es da Hörer, die da eine andere Meinung haben.
Ja, gibt es sogar und zwar den Henning. 0331 70 97 110 ist immer noch unsere Nummer. Henning, du findest elektronische Wahl sinnvoll?
Ich hätte überhaupt nichts dagegen vor, einen kleinen Computer zu treten vor der Wahl und da meine Stimme abzugeben. Allerdings würde ich dann keine Parteien mehr wählen wollen, sondern vielleicht die 10, 15, 20 wichtigsten Themen, zum Beispiel Ladenöffnungszeit, Tempolimit auf Autobahnen, Automahraustieg, Dosempfang. Da würde ich gerne wählen und nicht irgendwelche Parteien mehr.
Ja, aber was für Antworten willst du denn da geben? Ja, nein?
Ja, nein, genau.
Ja, aber es lassen sich ja nicht alle Fragen auf ja, nein runterbrechen. Also von daher kannst du das doch eigentlich auch gleich vergessen. Das wäre zwar irgendwie ganz schön, aber lässt sich halt nicht tun.
Also ich denke insgesamt ist Mitbestimmung ja nichts Falsches. Also eine der vier Kreuzen, die wir jetzt neulich gemacht haben hier in Berlin, war ja auch die Änderung der Verfassung, um ein Referendum zu vereinfachen.
Wie ist das eigentlich ausgegangen?
86 Prozent dafür.
Echt?
Das wäre auf jeden Fall ein Schritt zu mehr Demokratie.
Also sehe ich sicherlich auch so und das macht halt diese Geschichte mit den Internetwahlen so zweischneidig. Auf der einen Seite ist es etwas, wo man sagt, da könnte man mehr und eine direktere Demokratie mit erreichen. Und auf der anderen Seite gehen einem dabei auch demokratische Grundprinzipien verloren, nämlich die einer freien, gleichen und geheimen Wahl.
Du hast doch viel früher noch ein logistisches Problem. Es ist ja einfach nicht jeder Wahlberechtigte in der Lage, seine Stimme per Internet abzugeben. Also du kannst ja noch niemals sicherstellen, dass sie gleich ist in dem Moment.
Vielleicht noch ein anderes Thema, wenn man jetzt selber Wahlhelfer werden wollen würde, wenn jetzt so eine Computerwahl kommt oder elektronische Stimmabgabe. Wenn man sich das antut und danach einfach als Wahlhelfer Einspruch einlegt, hat man damit irgendwelche Erfolge. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, an Schleswig-Holstein mit dem Brief, mit dem Bleistift, mit dem Bleistift, Kreuzchen. Da hat dann einfach dieser Landeswahlleiter gesagt, ja, macht doch nix.
Das wäre wirklich eine interessante Frage, einfach Wahlhelfer.
Also ich denke, man hat dann auf jeden Fall viel Spaß.
Genau, wenn da jetzt auf einmal, ich weiß nicht, 217 Einsprüche, glaube ich, damals in Schleswig-Holstein, wenn das irgendwie 5000 Einsprüche von ganz Deutschland kommen, da dürfte der Wahlleiter schon in den Schwitzen kommen.
Also das ist sicherlich eine Möglichkeit, dass man sich mal bei der nächsten Wahl als Wahlhelfer anmeldet und dann irgendwie ordentlich seinen Dienst tut und dann hinterher sagt, das unterschreibe ich aber nicht, weil ich nicht sicherstellen kann, dass das Ergebnis in Ordnung ist. Und dann gucken wir, wie sie damit umgehen. Ich würde das jedem empfehlen als irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob es hilft gegen Wahlcomputer, aber es hilft auf jeden Fall, die Aufmerksamkeit auf dieses Problem zu nehmen. Zu den Bleistiffen, wenn wir das gerade hatten, da habe ich auch mal drüber nachgedacht, ob das ein Problem ist und habe dann festgestellt, bei den Wahlprozeduren, so wie wir sie haben, also Wahl ohne, und dann wird die geöffnet, und es wird ausgeschüttet und gezählt und so weiter und so fort, wann willst du denn das Kreuzchen wegradieren und dann anderes drauf machen, ohne dass es jemand merkt?
Es ist vordergründig, es ist sicherlich ein Problem, also ich habe mich damals ja auch sehr stark darüber eschofiert, aber wenn man das mal durchdenkt, ist es so schlimm nicht.
Nee, nee, es ist nicht das größte Risiko dabei.
Das sieht man ja auch, also du kriegst ja wirklich so einen Bleischift, nicht komplett entfernt, du hast ja mindestens noch den Aufdruck, und von daher sehe ich da eigentlich auch relativ wenig Probleme. Aber du hast gesagt, du hättest ja eigentlich kein Problem, dich vor so einer Maschine zu stellen. Was sagst du denn zu unseren anderen Kritikpunkten, die wir generell angebracht haben?
Also ich als Informatiker teile natürlich genau die gleiche Meinung. Ich kann halt überhaupt nicht reingucken in die Maschine. Egal, ob es irgendwelche Prüf-Summen rauskommen, die dann mit Print-Ausdruck verglichen werden können, was das für Footprint läuft, das kann man nicht wissen als Wähler. Und wenn ich als Informatiker vor der Maschine stehe, genauso. Das muss ja innerhalb von drei, vier Minuten passiert sein, wenn man die Stimmabgabe ausnimmt.
Aber trotzdem versprichst du dir sozusagen dann doch ab einem bestimmten Schwellwert einen Mehrwert, der dann unter Umständen diese Problematik dann übertrifft. Wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe. Du meintest ja, wenn ich jetzt über jeden kleinen Scheiß abstimmen könnte, wenn ich so einen Doppelklick habe für jede Einzelentscheidung, dann würde ich das sogar hinnehmen. Also ich halte das, insofern aus zwei Gründen halte ich das problematisch. Erstens ist das so ein Gedankending, wo man eben schnell mal vergisst, dass einfach die Black Box an sich ein Problem ist. Egal, was man am Ende da versprochen bekommt. Und dieses Ding mit mehr Demokratie, wenn man sich das mal durchdenkt, würde das ja bedeuten. Jede Frage, die dort entscheiden, entschieden werden muss, muss erstmal auf ein Ja-Nein runtergebrochen werden. Wir wissen ganz genau, dass die allermeisten Prozesse und politischen Entscheidungen nicht so ohne weiteres mit Ja-Nein, sondern sind immer so ein graustufiger Konsens in der einen oder anderen Form. Irgendjemand muss ja sozusagen auch schon diese Vorentscheidungen treffen, welche Frage da gestellt wird. Das sehe ich nicht. Ich sehe auch überhaupt nicht, dass die Leute in der Lage sind, sich innerhalb dieser kürzesten Zeit damit zu beschäftigen. Wir haben in der Schweiz so einen Wahlzettel gesehen, also so eine Wahlinformation, wo eben dann auch so spezifische regionale Abstimmungen drin waren. Ich glaube, das war dann irgendwie die Zustimmung zu der Erweiterung einer Schule oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, wo ich auch sagen würde, okay, das ist auch mal ein Thema, wo man in der Gemeinde vielleicht sogar im Kanton abstimmt. Da wurde dann einfach ein umfangreiches Booklet dazu gegeben, wo dann eben die ganzen Hintergründe und Zusammenhänge erklärt wurden, um dann eben dieses Thema auch zu verstehen. Aber sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, kostet relativ viel Zeit. Und das war vielleicht gerade noch zumutbar, aber dass jetzt jeder nach dem Frühstücksei irgendwie mal so eben ein paar Autobahnen beschließt, das sehe ich einfach nicht. Die Leute werden dann einfach irgendwas klicken und das Problem am Computer ist dann eben auch, dann machst du einfach eine Webseite auf, wo du dann einfach mal für die richtige Stimmeabgabe des Morgens, kriegst du einfach so und so viel Mega bei Porn. Und so kriegen die Leute heute auch irgendwie diese Captures umgangen. Die Leute geben einfach ein, was da auf dem Bildschirm steht und dafür gibt es Porn. Und mit dieser Währung kannst du einfach alles abfangen, was im Internet ist. Und das wollen wir doch wirklich nicht, dass wir die Demokratie gegen Porno tauschen. Ja Holger, ne?
Das versteht man wenigstens.
Wieso tauschen? Ich will Demokratie und Porn.
Pornokratie.
Genau, ein freier Pornofilm für jeden, der wählt. Genau. Das wäre mal was.
Das sind die Dinge, die meiner Tanke stehen. Der Punkt nochmal, also wenn du als Wahlhelfer hinterher nicht unterschreibst, dass du mit dem Ergebnis einverstanden bist, ist das nur romantische Vorstellung, die wir haben, oder hat das tatsächlich irgendeine Auswirkung? Also müssen von allen Wahlhelfern die Unterschriften da drauf sein, bevor das Ergebnis gültig ist. Weiß das jemand?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das einen Einfluss hat. Wer da der Wahlvorstand ist in dem jeweiligen Wahllokal, der muss sicherlich unterschreiben. Er kann vermerken, was es für Unregelmäßigkeiten gegeben hat. Aber man kann das damit nicht kippen.
Aber wenn man jetzt einen Einspruch erhebt... Bevor wir jetzt wild rumspekulieren, Henning, ich sag jetzt mal danke für deinen Anruf. Und es ergeht hier mit folgender Aufruf. Vielleicht hört hier noch jemand zu, der mal Wahlhelfer war und kann uns aufklären, was denn passiert, wenn dann am Ende das Wahllokal geschlossen wird und die Stimmen ausgezählt sind, ob da eine Unterschrift geleistet werden muss oder nicht. 0331 70 97 1 10 0. Für sachdienliche Hinweise an der Stelle wären wir dankbar.
Genau, es dürfen auch Leute anrufen, die schon angerufen haben.
Die Denkpause nutze ich mal, um mich, um über meine Nachbarn ein bisschen aufzuregen, in meinem Wahlkreis.
Ist hier Tim oder Ulrich?
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Nicht die unmittelbaren hier, sondern die Leute, die um mich wohnen, weil in meinem Wahllokal, also ich hab da mal geklickt, in meinem Wahlkreis, waren 38, 5 Prozent Wahlbeteiligung. 38, 5?
Wedding.
Krass.
Das ist wirklich krass.
Das war dann eher schlechtes Wedding als gutes Wedding.
Du warst mal Wahlhelfer.
Ja.
Musstest du irgendwas unterschreiben bei der Auszählung?
Na ja, zuerst mal musste ich unterschreiben, dass ich das Geld gekriegt hab. Die 26 Euro, Erfrischungsgeld oder wie das heißt.
26 Euro, du Gewinnler.
Ja, weil ich nicht im öffentlichen Dienst bin. Ach, die kriegen mehr? Die kriegen weniger, dafür kriegen sie einen Tag frei oder so. Und dann ist ganz am Ende vom Protokoll, da müssen wir alle noch mal unterschreiben. Und das haben sie auch alle brav gemacht. Ja, und das ist auf der drittletzten Seite von diesem Protokoll Vordruck. Und auf der vorletzten Seite, da ist dann noch ein Vordruck für es haben nicht unterschrieben folgende Wahlhelfer. Und noch ein paar Zeilen, wo man Gründe eintragen kann. Also das ist schon durchaus vorgesehen, dass da mal einer nicht unterschreibt.
Aber was passiert dann? Hat das irgendwelche Folgen?
Keine Ahnung. Ich glaube nicht. Also wenn ich mir auch angucke, nachher bei der Abgabe beim Stützpunkt, was die da alles angeguckt haben und was nicht. Also da könnte wahrscheinlich der größte Blödsinn drinstehen. Das fällt keinem auf. Also solange nur die Schnellmeldung durchgegeben wurde und die Summe stimmt. Also klar, es kann natürlich hinterher noch einer nachprüfen. Wenn jetzt einer nachfragt und sagt, ich fechte jetzt die Wahl an und das muss nachgezählt werden und das stimmt überhaupt nicht und so. Ich nehme an, die machen die Mappe dann schon mal auf und zählen danach, aber da müsste einer schon ziemlich hinterher rum nerven, sonst wird da nichts.
Wer im Wahllokal wäre denn dann überhaupt in der Lage zu sagen, dieses Ergebnis, was der Computer ausgespuckt hat, werden wir nicht anerkennen. Wir melden dieses Ergebnis nicht weiter. Gibt es die Möglichkeit überhaupt?
Na ja, vorgesehen ist das natürlich nicht. Ich hab ja noch nie so eine Computerwahl mitgemacht. Gibt es ja wohl auch so, weil es nicht Berlin ist ja pleite.
Da kann man aber viel Geld sparen, sagt der Hersteller.
Außerdem können wir ja die gebrauchten Maschinen aus Holland nehmen, wenn die abgesägt werden sollen. Aus Irland.
Ich sehe noch nicht, wo man da Geld sparen kann. Ob die Dinger so viel billiger sind als die Wahlhelfer, wenn die... Das ist noch die Frage.
Das wage ich auch stark zu bezweifeln. Also bei Computer hat man einfach so viel Folgekosten, allein schon durch die Systempflege und natürlich auch dadurch, dass man sich potenziell mal wieder von einem Hersteller abhängig macht. Also wenn es nicht so eine erdrückende Zahl von Negativargumenten gäbe für diese Technologie generell, dann überhaupt dann noch nur über den Weg eines Standards. Dass es sozusagen auch die Möglichkeit gibt, für mehrere Unternehmen dort auf gleichem Level zu arbeiten. Aber das spielt eigentlich gar keine Rolle mehr, aber das ist Quatsch.
Danke Alex. So, damit hätten wir unsere romantische Vorstellung von wir können als Wahlhelfer da was gegen Unternehmen auch beerdigt.
Hast du denn auch für diese Verfassungsänderung gestimmt?
Natürlich.
Und da warst du aber der Meinung, ich darf ja hier nicht wählen.
Ach so, du bist ja britischer Staatsbürger, ne? Du bist der, der den Irak überfallen hat. Das wär natürlich was, was wäre das sonst gewesen sein?
Ja, ich darf nur sehr selten wählen in diesem Land. Also diesmal hätte ich tatsächlich wieder wählen können zur... Also wie heißt das auf Regionalebene? Ich hab's vergessen. Aber ich war auch... Ich war auch im Ausland und irgendwie, ich hatte zwar Briefwahl beantragt, aber das hat mich irgendwie nicht erreicht und ich hatte dann keine Zeit oder Gelegenheit, dem hinterherzugehen. Dann ist sozusagen meine Stimme verfallen. Also ich bin so ein Nichtwähler. Ja, aber so WoWiWahl durfte ich halt nicht mitspielen. Das macht die Sache natürlich auch sehr unattraktiv.
Was jetzt, welche Sache?
Also auf Landesebene wählen. Da darfst du halt nur Local Shit wählen als Europäer.
Naja, aber wir haben ja eben gehört, dass gerade die BVV-Wahl doch eine sehr wichtige Wahl ist.
Ja, natürlich. Fühl mich jetzt auch schon ganz schlecht. Ich dich auch.
Das war das Chaosradio 107.
Echt, das war's schon?
Das war's schon, ja.
Oh Mann.
Das Thema war ein Wahlcomputer, wir waren dagegen. Hoffentlich haben wir diese Saat der Zweifel auch in eure Köpfe sehen können. Bitte schreibt auf den Abgeordneten.
Genau, und wenn ihr noch Feedback...
Oh Moment, das Thema hatten wir noch gar nicht, wenn ich aber unterbrechen darf. Wer trifft eigentlich die Entscheidung, diese Wahlcomputer anzuschaffeln?
Zu spät, Andreas, die Sendung ist zu Ende.
Dann machen wir es nicht.
Wer denn?
Die Gemeinde.
Redet mit eurer Gemeinde.
Genau, das ist recht mal ein Hinweis.
Die BVV-Wahl ist sehr wichtig, weil nämlich nachher...
Und du hast CDU gewählt.
Genau.
Das ist aber so ein schönes Lied irgendwie.
Ja, das hab ich auch schon. Das ist King Rocko Shamoni. Du wählst CDU, darum mach ich Schluss.
Ich muss jetzt aber ein paar URLs fallen lassen zu dem Thema.
Das macht mich fertig.
Aber diesmal nicht mit ganz so viel Pathos.
Trotzdem warte ich den Tusch ab.
Also Chaosradio 117, das war's. Und wir haben das Wiki, wiki.chaosradio.ch. Da gibt es eine Mitmach-Seite. Die meisten von euch kennen das wahrscheinlich. Wer es noch nicht kennt, guckt sich das mal an. Und wenn ihr ein paar lustige URLs habt zu dem Thema, Artikel und so, da ist schon einiges verlinkt, dann packt ihr das einfach mal da rein. Auch für die nächste Sendung wird es wieder so eine Seite geben. Was wir ein bisschen unter den Tisch fallen lassen haben, diesmal ist die Sache mit der Timeline. Da hatte ich letztes Mal so großkostlich versprochen, dass ich mal diese Version mache. Ich bin einfach nicht dazu gekommen, ich war unterwegs. Nehm ich das noch an. Ein Hörer hat sogar ein kleines Skript gehackt, da bin ich auch noch nicht dazu gekommen, das mal zu evaluieren. Das machen wir alles nächste Mal. Es gibt auf BerlinCCC.de unter Wahlcomputer-Wahlmaschinen unter dem Thema auch eine längere Zusammenfassung zu dem Thema, die Ulrich im Wesentlichen pflegt. Das sind mehrere Seiten sehr umfangreiche Zusammenfassungen, insbesondere zu dem aktuellen legalen Status. Also in welchen Ländern gibt es schon Wahlcomputer, in welchen Bezirken usw. Also wenn ihr euch dafür interessiert, ob in eurem Bereich das zutrifft, dann könnt ihr das dort schauen. Fallen euch noch ein paar wichtige Ressourcen ein zu dem Thema oder habe ich schon alles genannt?
Da ist auf jeden Fall alles verlinkt.
Da ist auf jeden Fall alles verlinkt, gelocht, geheftet und abgestempelt.
Chaosradio 117 war das. Das nächste Chaosradio gibt es am letzten Mittwoch im Oktober. Vielen Dank, Tim. Vielen Dank, Andreas. Vielen Dank, Ulrich.
Vielen Dank, Holger.
Es geht weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf. Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit und nicht vergessen.